Now I thought a new intro theme was just the sound of an air conditioner.
Good experience.
[inaudible]
today is,
uh,
December 22nd,
2014,
and,
uh,
Joe Cocker died today and fuck man.
Dot.
Guy was a bad mother fucker.
I mean,
what a unique singer.
What a powerful personality.
That guy was amazing.
He was so fucking cool to watch that guy sing.
And when John Belushi did his impression assignment live,
do you remember that?
I don't know.
Oh my God,
it was brilliant.
But this is,
this is,
uh,
Joe Cocker at Woodstock.
So this is like,
I guess this is 1969.
That's when Woodstock was right.
69.
He was just such a unique dude.
Like I can't,
I can't think of any other singer that came before him or after him that was
like quite like him.
He's so,
he was so Joe cocker,
you know,
I mean,
it was just like this big sweaty English dude is crazy fucked up hair doing the
air guitar on stage and squeeze notes out of the air guitar that no one else
could.
Yeah.
And it was like he didn't,
you didn't mind it at all,
like you know what I mean?
Like there's something like inherently do,
she brought the lead singer do an air guitar.
Right.
But these were Maroon five concert.
I would be throwing water bottles at the stage.
But you feel his energy immediately.
If it was Nickelback there'd be a riot and that'd be right
there cause I fucking loved him
too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
I will sign that acute
[inaudible]
damn two was good.
The last from lung cancer,
probably smoking well knows maybe.
Maybe working in bars.
You know,
I was talking to someone at the comedy store the other day.
We were talking about this how it's amazing how no comedy clubs have smoking
anymore.
Like it used to be when we started,
every comedy club you would go to,
it was like Tupac minimum.
You'd walk in there and just be
people constantly puffer to every bar you would go to.
Used to be like that.
Most of the performers to,
yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of the performers and for performers who had quit,
do you know how hard that must be?
If you quit cigarettes and you'd go to a place where everyone's smoking and a
smokes in the air.
So you're essentially taking that nicotine in and it's firing up all those
addictive little pockets that you have that were dormant.
All Kevin.
I see.
Why smoke again?
Oh,
I love it.
Like,
no,
no.
We're not smoking.
This is called secondhand smoke.
We're in a bar.
Well let's,
you're kidding you.
They,
we,
she'd probably kiss,
get along.
Just get a couple puffs on a little bit.
Tastes so good.
Why don't you just jam a whole bunch in your mouth hole?
Oh,
fun.
What are we on for Kevin?
Let's light this thing.
Let's breathe in.
You know,
it's taken the full dose.
That's what it's like to be at the comedy store when he quit.
Like every time you quit smoking or quit smoking and then go to the calm to her,
everybody smoking for any comment on the outside.
But imagine you're up on stage and people are just exalting their appreciation
by blowing things of this addictive chemical right into your nostrils,
but must be super hard to quit.
And also if they're alcoholics,
if you're an alcoholic and you're at a comedy club,
like everybody's drinking,
Chappelle still smokes on stage,
he doesn't give a shit.
He'll go right into the comedy story,
light up a pack of cigarettes and just smoked a whole pack there.
Well,
you know,
you're kind of allowed to onstage.
I think there's some loophole in the law that allows for you to smoke for a
theatricals under for performance art.
Right?
Or something like that.
The same reason you're allowed to have power tools in a metal bra and shoots
sparks everywhere and it really cramped studio.
I mean it's performance art.
Well if you had a cigar on stage,
like if you were playing Mark Twain and that was like part of your prop,
you had a light,
a cigar and pontificate on the universe,
you a,
you would be allowed to use that.
They should be able to use bubblegum pipes.
Are Those bubble pipes on Broadway?
Oh,
those old school ones.
Yeah.
You wear the red velvet smoking jacket and tried to deliver a really serious
line and then just pluma bubbles coming out.
Have you ever been to the place in New York where they have the pipes in the
wall now it's that there's a steakhouse in New York.
Brian,
see if he could Google the name of the place.
I forget it,
but Sussman recommended it to me.
We went there once and it's been open I guess for like,
you know,
150 years or something crazy.
And it has all these pipes on the wall.
Like tobacco smoking pipe,
tobacco pipes from famous P,
right.
So I guess people would go and eat steak there and just smoke pipes and they
would take down their pipe like they had like a little wall.
What was it called?
Uh,
it's called Keen's steakhouse.
There you go.
That's old school.
Here's that.
Here's a photo of it.
Right?
When was that latest pie?
Oh look,
those are all pipes on the ceiling surrounded by framed racists.
Look it up.
Yeah.
That guy didn't even pretend you had black friends.
I don't even want the frame around me to be black.
You find some find some Brazilian walnut.
You know,
there was a photo.
We're,
we're having this podcast just a few days after these two New York City cops
were executed in their cop car in Brooklyn by this guy who was a,
he was already on a run.
I mean he,
he shot and killed his girlfriend or critically wounded three stars.
He was trying to unlock the tank.
I don't know those,
those video game roles.
But um,
then then there was a photo that was released from 1959,
I think it was of miles Davis.
Miles Davis had walked some white girl to her car,
to a cab and these police officers,
a friend,
he'd walked a white friend and these police officers beat the shit out of him
and arrested him.
And this picture is a miles Davis.
Yeah,
there's pictures of miles Davis got blood all over him.
You're like,
Whoa,
witch's brew all you just realize that like that
been going on for a long fucking time.
Police brutality.
But the good news is now we have first person POV video from lapel cams and it
still can't get an indictment.
So we're fine.
Right.
Win Win for both sides.
Well,
you know,
I think that the Eric Gardner one is insanely unfortunate,
insanely unfortunate,
and insanely unnecessary.
Like the what they did.
I think the,
the incident is unfortunate,
but I think the lack of fucking trial that's criminal in and of itself,
well
just doesn't make any sense unless that's your protocol.
If that's your protocol,
you've got to change your protocol.
If you're saying that he did nothing wrong,
well then you gotta redefine what's wrong.
Sure.
Because this guy was just selling cigarettes,
man.
You know what I mean?
Jesus fucking Christ.
He wasn't wanted for some other crimes,
but also they defined what's wrong.
They've,
the choke hold is already illegal.
It's already band.
And when the corner of rules it a homicide via chokehold,
you don't,
you don't rule against that.
Like they've already decided.
So that's illegal.
And with the coroner said,
that's what [inaudible] said it was homicide was like heart failure due to
diabetes or something like that.
No,
no.
That was the issue that the corner,
the corner himself ruled it a homicide.
Wow.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
Well,
and then they go.
And then,
you know,
you've watched the Fox News where there yapping about like,
well it's not a chokehold.
Listen,
I've taken,
I'm a green belt in Brazilian Jujitsu.
I took a class next to an orange Julius.
So there was a,
it was from Fox and friends,
I think where they were talking about that.
He's like,
I know Kung Fu,
I've seen the matrix.
And that wasn't a chokehold.
There's different ways to apply pressure to the neck and you would know that if
you were a mixed martial artist,
couldn't believe it's Hannity,
I think.
Couldn't believe it.
Um,
this guy,
uh,
this medical examiner says he was killed by compression of his chest and prone
positioning during physical restraint by the police,
asthma,
heart attack and obesity.
We're contributing factors.
So I don't think we're supposed to say that it was a,
the choke hold it did that I had to connect because I could've sworn I read that
it was,
uh,
the
choke hold.
But let's say,
what was the first part of that?
It will be,
it's a different striction of airway,
wasn't that?
Yeah,
I mean,
what else is that?
Oh,
well mean I guess you could argue it's a knee on the chest.
No,
it's more of a,
I'm not arguing that they,
they that indicate that the interaction with the cops kill them.
They,
the cops definitely killed them.
Sure.
What I'm saying is I don't think that means that it was from his neck.
I think it's compression of his chest and uh,
all of it is related to the cops.
But I don't think it's related to that illegal move specifically to the armor on
the now.
Right.
But the idea that,
yeah,
this is what they're saying.
Uh,
compression of the neck.
Okay.
Now the medical,
this is a different thing.
The medical,
okay.
This is the God damn problem with the Internet.
You're reading these stories and these people have their own agenda.
So I apologize.
The autopsy,
those feed article that found that the cement was at fault.
So,
okay.
This is,
This was,
um,
in this article they're saying that the,
that he was,
he died from compression of the neck and also compression of the chest and the
prone positioning.
So it was a contributing factors.
What you're saying,
it wasn't that the dude was out of shape and needed more cardio in his life.
Oh,
they killed them attributed but it was compression of his neck.
That's a choke hold.
Right,
exactly.
Well,
how else do you rule that?
Yeah,
well they without a doubt they killed him in this altercation like this
altercate I mean,
yeah,
he didn't have the best of health and and yeah,
he did resist them.
Arresting him for no fucking reason,
but they should have been arresting him.
He rose him doing anything and they were wrong.
He didn't even have any cigarettes on him.
Right.
If this guy was selling loose cigarettes like come on man,
you're going to physically attack a guy.
Like it becomes a matter of this is how we need to look at instead of laws like
this is the law.
Does the law when you are doing that,
you are essentially an arm thug for the tax collectors should not really,
you're not doing police work anymore.
Okay.
Because police work in the most noble of ways is to serve and protect the idea
of a cop in the best possible position is someone who's there to protect adverse
citizens from horrible people.
That's the beautiful aspects.
So as soon
you had to keep and maintain the piece to be clear,
not to rile it up.
Right,
but that's,
see,
that's not technically what they're supposed to do.
Technically.
What they're supposed to do is uphold the law and uphold the whatever.
You know
there are statute four 17 says that you're holding this thing on a Sunday on
this sidewalk and that is illegal.
This is a red zone and I'm going to harass you.
And because you're tired of systemic harassment,
perhaps that's happened to you for years and years and years,
and that gunk is built on the machine.
You do want to resist me because I'm enforcing this law upon you.
Yeah.
One of the things he said is,
he said this,
this ends today.
Yeah,
that's what he was saying while they were,
while they were about to attack him.
Right.
Leave me the fuck alone.
It's so easy for,
I'd see the Facebook articles that pop up in my timeline that my own family
members are posting,
and it's so easy to a meme with big capital text on it that says,
hey man,
shouldn't be resisting if you weren't resisting,
that wouldn't happen.
And I go,
listen,
you don't have to resist each and every fucking day.
You have no idea what their life is like.
And this isn't a city with stop and frisk laws where you're just casually
walking down the wrong street and you happened to be the wrong color.
So you're going to get roughed up.
We're going to have your pockets inverted.
I think a lot of people have really racist ideas and they don't realize that
they're really racist ideas.
And a lot of people have these notions about what it's like to be someone who
lives in x or y neighborhood,
you know?
And you're living in,
you know,
you're in c town judging those x's and y's.
Yeah.
You're in some fucking beautiful suburb somewhere with a bunch of white people
and you're pretending that you understand what it's like to be living in a
horrible neighborhood.
To be a guy who's been arrested 30 times.
What?
What the fuck is that guy's life been like?
What does his life been like since childhood?
When you say that guy's been arrested 31 times,
like this guy,
you got to go,
Whoa,
hold the fuck on.
Like when did that start?
How old was he?
Was he like 16 when he first got arrested?
Like this guy,
does this guy ever have a chance or was he shot out of the womb into a sea of
chaos and,
and this is a minor thing.
I mean you're gonna,
you're gonna attack this guy physically over cigarettes.
That's crazy.
So if they are saying that they're just abiding by the law and they thought that
they were supposed to do that,
we have to rethink what the fuck the law does cause the law can't do that cause
you're not a cop then you are a fucking revenue collector.
Laws.
It's,
it's so crazy to me that there are quotas in that profession.
You've got to meet your quota,
which is why at the end of the month you're getting pulled over for speeding a
little bit more and certain areas are getting stopped and frisked and war just
got,
they got to get the numbers up.
They got to look at the spreadsheet and that line graph has to plot up.
Why?
Why isn't a Yelp based sort of thing?
Why isn't it the people deciding?
Have the cops been helpful to them?
Have they serviced them if they kept the peace?
You know,
it's an archaic system.
The idea of police officers,
It really is.
I mean,
I think we need it.
Yes,
no doubt.
Absolutely need it.
Absolutely need military.
We should absolutely.
We don't live in a utopian perfect paradise,
but the system that's in place right now is so archaic.
Correct.
The metrics are off.
This shit,
the quotas and then this shit of like grabbing a guy in wrestling him to the
ground because he's not paying cigarette taxes.
Right.
You know who he is.
He poses no threat whatsoever.
He's telling you he can't breathe,
which those are weird crimes,
man.
I mean,
there was so many people saying,
well clearly he can breathe cause he's shouting he can't breathe.
But it's been proven time and time again that your lungs,
there's reserve air in there.
Even if you can't breathe that you can use to get in sometimes minutes worth of
conversation out.
Well,
I can help out on a couple of these points that people are debating.
First of all,
that's a fucking choke hold.
Okay,
I know how to choke people call it for a living.
That's a chokehold.
When a guy has his arm around his neck like that,
that's compression of the neck,
but then then it becomes,
how did he actually use it?
C I s you know I even tweeted,
I'm like,
that's a fucking choke hold.
You can't say it's not,
but here's the question.
How much pressure was he applying on the neck?
That's when it becomes a choke hold.
When you,
when you are grabbing and you're pulling on the neck and closing off the
arteries,
that's when it becomes a chokehold.
It could be that he's loosely hold the neck and place.
But the problem is the autopsy says that that wasn't the case.
If the autopsy says he was choked and he was fucking choke if he had compression
of the neck.
So what it's saying,
the medical examiner saying compression of the neck,
compression to the chest,
and a prone position,
prone positioning during physical restraint by the police.
This is like in quotes.
So if this,
all of these things are all like using force on a person's body and all those
things can stop you from breathing.
Like when you're doing Jujitsu,
there's,
there's positions where you can't breathe,
where you're not getting choked.
Like there's positions where guys have like a knee on your belly and they
grabbed you around the back and they're pulling towards you.
They compress your chest so,
so deeply and painfully that you can't fucking breathe.
And this is for people who do Jujitsu.
Like if,
if,
uh,
you know,
someone's on top of me and they're grabbing the back of my neck and they're
shoving a knee into my chest,
it's really hard to breathe.
And you know,
I've done Jujitsu for 20 years.
So for,
for a dude who's like a very overweight guy with diabetes,
he's,
you know,
he's not physically fit at all and he's an older guy and you know,
he's,
he's not planking for fun.
Yeah.
He's really overweight and so they're on top of this guy and they're doing all
that to him.
Who knows how much resistance he has to their body weight.
Who knows how much it takes before he can't breathe.
Some people are not healthy and if all you have to do is push them to corner and
smoosh them and they'll,
they'll look at Gabriel breathe and they could die.
Like that's not uncommon.
There's people out there that are that fucking unhealthy.
And the,
I get the argument of yeah,
you shouldn't be that unhealthy and you'll put that doesn't matter.
Well,
you know,
who's putting those fat fingers in America doing that dude elastically boobs.
This,
these things that you just said about resisting arrest and like I've seen in my
Facebook timeline and I had to run side all that.
Come on,
man.
He shouldn't have been so fat.
Really,
he shouldn't have died.
I live,
this is not,
it's sad.
I the other day fell asleep while trying to power level in destiny.
Joe and I almost choked myself.
I don't know.
I don't know what that meant was on the couch.
Like this power leveling you're trying to get to 30 so I can enjoy the rates.
It's cool.
I'll teach you.
And destiny is a game.
Destiny is in fact a video.
You fill us all in a video game.
Young and non,
you don't,
you don't need to know the specifics of it.
You don't want to know the specifics but I isn't that frightening suck you in.
I mean a few months really love repetitive gameplay and keeping up with the
Joneses with virtual items.
Yeah.
She get it.
Do you shoot things or no?
Shoot.
Lots of things.
Lots of aliens and lots of robots.
Really?
Yeah.
Sounds to involve.
So you stay away from it.
So.
So you almost blacked out?
No.
I literally,
I fell asleep on the couch and I had my neck just like this,
and I kind of choked myself out as I fell and had
to wait before falling asleep,
watching a TV show,
right?
You're head goes down,
you're like,
I'm fucking,
yeah,
you could kill people.
Then it's like some people aren't,
aren't,
aren't very fit.
So there will be justice on the civil side,
which is even more infuriating because that means it's our tax dollars that are
going to pay to settle this guy's illegal maneuver.
This is the latest.
This is all just so unnecessary.
This is what's fucked up about it.
It's just so God damn unnecessary.
Yeah.
I mean this,
this attitude of like this is,
imagine if there were no crimes,
no crimes ever militia,
man.
Nowhere in the world,
everything is beautiful.
Everything is like this room.
We all get along famously,
the entire human race could imagine if we got to a point where the entire human
race is just totally cool with each other,
and this would be like a major crime.
Now,
if this was like our major crime and we saw cops attack this guy like this,
we would recognize the cops for being the bad guys,
right?
Like if there was no real crimes and all this guy was doing it,
this is like the worst thing ever.
He's not paying all the taxes on the cigarettes.
I mean that's it.
And so we saw a bunch of guys jump on this guy because he wasn't paying
cigarette taxes.
We'd told you fucking thugs.
Those are IRS thugs that are going after this guy.
We've got to fucking help that dude.
You know,
fuck these people.
These people are Merck's,
that shouldn't be the police force.
It just shouldn't,
you know?
And whether it's for speeding tickets or whether it's for petty crimes or if you
really do have a quota on arrests,
you're betting against the public.
Like that's what you're doing.
Like what would you do if no one committed crimes anymore?
Right?
If the whole country did become like this room where everybody's just chilling,
what would we do?
What would we do?
If ever where you could go.
You would never have to worry about being robbed or never have to worry about
defending yourself.
It was just everywhere you go and be like,
what's up soap?
It's up.
I mean,
if everybody was cool,
literally that would be the world that we would live in.
Well,
what the fuck?
If that was the case,
what would the cops do?
I need someone to police the cool factor.
Like you're being too chill.
You need to fucking rage it up your way to mellow.
Sorry sir.
We,
uh,
just check the list.
You are the 1000000th guy with an ironic fedora on and we can't let you through.
There's too many of you.
We already had a 12 hour drum circle.
We can't have a 13th that's the rule.
I'm going to have to throw it against a brick wall.
How many fucking Guido's were inspired by the soprano's to go out and put on a
warm up suit and just like go out to the Delis and hang out and wrap up the
fucking Italian fucking Italian became good.
It became like,
like pleasurable to be a Guinea douchebag as my relative.
So call ourselves,
you know,
like it became like a good thing.
It became like a badge of courage is fucking a tiling is we've got to stay
together.
These folk got Italians over here,
we make the best buy.
Lowes the best fucking man.
It became like,
you know what I mean?
It became like a thing.
I don't know how we got there.
Point being New York City's a fucking,
it's a cauldron of anger,
you know,
and does it.
It ain't,
you know,
it's not,
it's not the cops fault.
They,
they're,
I believe they're stuck in this system that's been there long before the guys
who are in there now we're running in New York City.
You know,
I think that like you dealing with a lot of crime,
you're dealing with a lot of violence in it.
You've got a bunch of hard men that are in charge of taking care of that shit
because that's what you need when you're running a police force.
And that's just Wall Street [inaudible] in a different way.
But you know,
there needs to be some sort of fucking cease fire,
some sort of a,
you know,
a communion with the people in the police because the police are the people and
this is where everybody's getting fucked up.
There's this
them thing that happens.
You get one triple armor plated,
mine sweeping Humvee orb school bus or whatever retrofitted it's been from
Afghanistan or whatever.
Your department gets one.
Yeah,
that's all you're going to need pass that.
You got to donate to schools and fix roads and get some high speed fucking
Internet.
Yeah,
that's totally true.
Except if something happens like what happened in the North Hollywood shootout?
Do you remember the north and do you remember that?
Yeah,
Dude.
We were on news radio on the set and that shit was going down and everybody was
in the,
I don't know,
I forget what room we're in.
We're watching it.
We were all bundled up together.
We were like Ho Lee Shit.
This is crazy.
There was a guy walking down the street,
just gone in,
people down with our head to toe Arbor played him my fucking ironman movie like
an iron man,
like a bad guy in heat,
you know,
like more eggs,
more exaggerated than heat.
Right.
Cause he was more armored up,
right.
That they have to be ready in case some shit like that happens.
They were ready and they are ready today.
It's like the barely ready for that.
They were super outgunned in that they figured it out.
They barely did with those because there was only two dudes.
You know,
I mean look,
I'm not saying that we should have a militarized police force,
but the reality is if a military attack did occur on a city,
the police force is not equipped to defend against it.
They're equipped to totally true.
But what we've also seen time and time again,
it's that they don't have the proper judgment as to when that use or show of
force as necessary.
And that's why you see fucking tanks and snipers in prone positions at peaceful
Ferguson protests.
I mean that.
So it's like it's,
it's the who watches the watchmen thing,
right?
They need the gear to protect us from the fucking handful of crazies that once a
decade come out and have their little parade.
Yeah.
But who gets to dictate when and how they can use that gear if they in and of
themselves,
they're corrupt or they've got corrupt motives.
Yeah.
Fuck.
As long as we don't show the interview,
we're all safe.
That's what it comes down to.
Well,
it all comes down to,
first of all,
there has to be some sort of accountability for public's reaction.
The reaction the public has had,
especially the one that kills
me,
is that 12 year old kid in Cleveland,
that one kills me.
I can't even read about that one guy.
One fucked my head up.
I don't think I know about that one.
Do I want to know about that?
One kid had a toy gun,
uh,
and these cops pulled over and they shot him within two seconds of seeing him.
They killed him within,
literally,
there's a video that car stopped,
the car opens up.
He pulls his gun out and he starts shooting and he kills the kid and it's like,
what the fuck?
I can't watch it.
I won't watch it.
There's also last night I finally the the the officer with the Lapel Cam who
calls to dogs over and then shoots them.
She literally makes the kissing noises then at the dogs and calls him over and
then drops them both and then radios it in now.
Now supposedly she was responding to a call where these dogs were attacking
someone and they were trapped in like a truck and she needed to get through
these dogs.
The issue is that,
and now granted they released the vine version of this video.
I don't know what the handles are on either side,
but you do see in this video or these two dogs,
their tails wagging,
zero barks and she pulls the calls him over and then you see just like a first
person shooter,
you see the revolver come up.
Yeah.
And the trigger squeezed and it's just like another case of like,
okay,
now we're seeing it.
Now we're seeing it.
Do you know about the guy who was a mayor somewhere and the,
the cops got the wrong address.
There was a guy who was getting pot delivered and what he was doing is he was
using this guys that dress.
Do you remember the store?
It was ugly somewhere outside of Washington.
Is this
bang the house and the kid got scarred or no,
no,
no.
So different.
That one I think was in Atlanta.
This is a different one.
So,
so many these days.
Joe [inaudible] House lose track,
shot his dog,
chased the dog down and shot it in front of the kids and,
and handcuffed everybody.
The whole deal went through the house and then found out that the guy was
actually the mayor.
And you know,
the whole thing was just like this shoe or a mayor at least through the whole
thing was a fucking huge disaster.
But you found out like firsthand from a guy who's in government how thuggish
there,
right?
Like they ran after a Labrador and shot it.
I called Labradors.
Anybody who's knows labs like the sweetest,
friendliest dogs in the world.
And if you,
you don't know that,
you don't know if the dog's not barking and attacking you and you shoot it,
you,
you just murdered a dog.
Right?
You know,
you just murdered a family pet.
That's crazy that they have that attitude.
But that's so prevalent.
It happens so often.
That's the case in point.
Like had that happened to someone who just happens to work in a cafeteria or
someone who picks up garbage,
you probably wouldn't have heard about it would have made it nowhere.
They just happen,
knock on the one wrong door that had a government official in there.
And then the same question again comes up is that protocol and if it is protocol
than protocols fucked up,
that's fucked up.
You know,
we got,
if there was only a few people have as a small town,
you would never accept that kind of behavior from the cop.
Right.
The idea is the only time that behavior becomes is
when the cop is not a part of the community.
When the cop is from somewhere else and comes in and can shoot that dog and
doesn't have to worry about sleeping in his house right next door to where he
shot that dog,
he can make a mess up in an area and just get out of there.
Right.
That's the problem with urbanization when it comes to like the way people treat
each other inside communities.
That was a problem that happened when squad cars became more prevalent that that
the on the streets policing used to have to walk a beat and make eye contact
with your neighbors and you weren't in a metal cage of course with a shotgun
there and surrounded by technology and everything.
And they said that once police officer's switched to that,
their patrols got larger.
So the intimacy dropped and you know,
that sense of community a vanished and it's so painful for me to talk about in
this way because I've got my brother's a cop,
I've got so many police officers in my family and so when I write the long
winded diatribes in response to moderately racist,
you know,
tea party action network means that I see pop up in my Facebook timeline.
I do like,
I always make it a point to say,
I know that they deal with the worst of the worst,
right?
Every day they deal with scumbags or they deal with people who want to kill them
or rape people or what.
Yes,
they deal with that,
but it doesn't excuse any of this.
I'm sorry.
That's part,
I'm glad that they're there.
I'm glad that they keep me safe.
If some shit goes down,
the first thing you did call the cops,
right?
That's who we would turn to.
But it doesn't excuse any of this behavior.
And you have to also admit that those constant interactions day to day,
dealing with people that you think don't.
If it's a routine traffic stop,
you have to in a piece piece of your brain has to fire off going,
this guy wants to fucking kill me.
He,
you never know that that constant pain in your brain has got to warp your vision
on everybody else.
There's no way to keep those feelings silo.
This has been a reoccurring subject lately.
If people were tired of us talking about it.
Oh yeah.
Well it's,
it's just so in the news,
right.
Sampling so much tucked destiny.
Now what level are you,
because I find if you get to 20,
then it's all about your light level and then you're fucking funding for
legendary and grams.
And you know what a pain in the ass that is 10.
You got an upgrade them and I don't have enough fucking spin metal for that.
Am I right?
I appreciate your passion.
At least I'm passionate about a topic.
No,
not what you discuss,
sir.
But I appreciate your passion.
I'm not trying to dissuade us from the topic.
I'm just trying to sort of acknowledge the fact that I know we talk about it a
lot.
Sure.
It's,
um,
it's,
I don't think people are qualified to be policed.
I think it's too hard to,
John for humans.
I think we need robot police.
Oh,
we're getting some fucking I robot type dudes.
Yeah.
And as long as criminal stay off the stairs and two and nine,
it's got a man he's set.
Make sure there's nothing to do with taxes and nothing to do with revenue
collection.
You can't arrest people for stuff like that.
Right.
Just take it up in court.
Robot police that you can fuck when they're not doing anymore.
That's not how the world's going to work.
But think about it.
They got it running around fucking the police.
They got to recharge at some point.
Fuck the police from the underground.
No,
seriously.
Fuck them.
They're recharging right now.
Maybe that's what it became a strategy that was devised by a psychologist who
really let everybody know,
listen,
if we're all making love,
will,
will respect and appreciate each morning and it'll give the people a stronger
bond with the police.
So they actually should fuck the police officers when they find them.
Yes.
So the police could do after orgasm,
the robot police could serve a dual purpose.
They could enforce laws and blow you,
you know,
so you really feel good about interacting with them.
Let's take action steps though.
Okay.
I mean,
we know robot fuckable police like bipedal robots.
The technology's not quite there.
They're getting there.
The one time I fuck it.
It'll be there.
I'm not fucking Beta subjects.
I'm not trying any,
uh,
not going to fucking Google ass.
I'm not going to,
no,
I'm saying I'm not yet early.
Adopt doing any,
yeah.
I'm not going to be an early adopter.
I'm going to fuck the Primo units that are ready.
We could have won my ticket and electrocuted off.
You know,
some dudes,
one dude,
the chicks going to have some sort of a blow out inside of her and his Dick's
going to get cooked to a crisp.
Yeah,
but then got to run on electricity.
New firmware.
You're set.
Yeah.
The,
the maybe replaced for utility belts today with just,
just like a bandolier,
a fleshlight holes.
That's about it.
And you could go up and hug your local police officer and go ahead and give him
a little couple thrusts at the waist level.
I'm no,
I know him.
Him or her,
like all robot girl.
Look man,
it's going to be 10 years before this tech is ready.
So let's throw flashlights on officers.
How many women would be into fucking robot dudes as opposed to the dude's being
a fucking robot.
Women.
Cause for Dudes,
I could think,
I can comfortably say it's a hundred percent a hundred percent guys would fuck a
lifelike,
beautiful woman robot.
Right.
But I don't,
we're not even lie.
Same with women with women.
I don't think are 100% of women would fuck a robot.
I bet.
I bet they're way more discerning.
I bet most of my ex girlfriends would say that they have fucked a robot.
He had a,
uh,
emotionless machine that is just the driving for the finish.
They would make love to the robot.
That's exactly [inaudible] a wonderful [inaudible] asked me about my day.
I him with the rubber would look like of chicks could design it.
That's what the real question was.
Saddle will be like,
do you think it would even be white?
Would it be like,
would it be blue,
like avatar style?
I think it'd be red.
If girls could make a guy like any color they want,
would they do,
they would probably make us pink,
giant transparent so they could see our feelings.
I want to know what's going on in their transparent.
Just,
yeah,
I can't wait cause the,
the,
the future of that is LEDs that are customized with the music that's going on to
two robot fucking,
yeah.
Her mouth changes colors based on the Scrillex track that's going,
you know,
like it's going to be wild fucking rave.
That was pretty psychedelic.
Especially thinking about how small the LEDs could possibly get.
Right.
You know,
like literally her whole face.
It could be pores and the,
the,
the actual pores of the face could be like individual LEDs.
Well we think about how cool projection mapping is,
right?
Sling an image onto a surface and oh it looks,
it's that thing when,
when the LEDs are small enough to basically be those individual pores are
pixels.
The entire surface can animate and come to life in a way that admits its own
light.
So you can walk around and you could,
you could change the face of it.
You can change the texture,
you could change whatever.
It can be full motion video playing on your fuck doll's face will.
You could show like commercials,
like if you're doing a doggy style show commercials on her back after a Purina
dog chow.
Yeah.
They could just like interrupt your sex for commercials yet.
Like you get a sex program,
but you have to watch like a certain amount of minutes.
Have a coca cola commercial.
Right?
So you watched this polar bear dance around ice on the small of her back while
you try to keep your heart off and like she freezes while the commercials going
on.
She won't move and it just dries up all of a sudden.
Well it just holds like a fucking metal and not,
not,
not scary,
but gives you a little extra squeeze.
Just stay right here.
Watch this coke commercial.
Don,
look at the new fiesta.
Look at how heavy it is by cook.
After you,
fuck me.
Right baby,
who's six back [inaudible] they're going to holiday or sneezes.
When you finish it,
it's nose robot places are going to have to have juice,
right.
So they're going to have like simulated smells.
Awesome.
So you could have like,
I wouldn't keep the Strawberry Pussy Jews or you could be like,
no,
I want realistic pussy smell.
Yeah,
you're probably going to be able to customize everything Cinnabon.
It's going to be like kind of constantly smell like an airport.
You could totally do that on a food court.
Right.
Dot.
Yeah.
They can do that.
Or like some people would want someone to smell like an animal.
Like want to smell like a dog,
right?
Oh yeah.
Maybe a wet dog dog.
Some people like really into like animalistic sex.
I'm on salmon and you smell like a fucking moose.
Dirty
dirty feet.
Concert breath,
cigarette breath,
arm pits.
Bad vitamins.
Yeah.
You're going to be able to have sex with movie stars.
Well,
there was that one thing they're going to be able to like do a Jennifer Lopez
model,
you know,
and Jennifer Lopez is going to show up at your house and just start blowing you.
And we talked about this.
There's going to be a marketplace for this on Oculus to start in Vr,
right?
And there'll be an underground marketplace where hackers texture map your
favorite actor or actress onto a 3d fuck model and you'll be able to download
and people will be pirating people's likenesses and making the same way they
make soundboard.
So I'll make these sort of fuck audio tracks so you can go and download your
favorite celeb and pay,
you know,
some,
some underground group,
a couple bucks to have access to that three d model.
I am totally in a time,
I envision a time in our lifetimes where people regularly have like implants put
under the skin of their head.
Like,
you know,
how they,
they're doing all these different,
um,
there was a,
an episode of,
um,
radio lab where they were talking about how they've applied electrical impulses
to certain areas of the brain to stimulate learning.
Right.
And people have done things like these,
uh,
videos,
sniper
courses,
and they do it with the electrical impulses in their,
their scores go through the fucking roof just through the roof.
And these are just these electrodes that are placed on the head.
If you,
if we permanently installed some sort of battery powered system that was like on
top of people's heads and people were constantly connected to this and could
connect to each other back and forth with this.
I mean the,
I think that that's something that would,
that would be implemented like almost like the cell phone is today.
People would just get it because they would want to have it.
Yeah.
Some enhanced to learning device.
And now of course I'll pop it on during my formative years and I can read that
the speed of Johnny five and great.
And that'll just become commonplace.
Yeah.
According on it,
it'll upload to the cloud.
You'll probably be able to take pictures of your eyeballs and now you can send a
photograph to you're a doctor,
your ophthalmologist,
and you'd go,
Oh gee,
does how you're seeing shit.
Oh,
you silly bitch.
You got 2040 vision.
You need glasses.
What's 2040 is okay,
right?
What's bad?
Like 2050 2060 let's,
I don't know what the numbers are.
20 is best and then look to see actually some people have better than 2020 like
fighter pilots and shit.
Those fucking real red blooded Americans and only eat corn flakes in the
morning.
I fucking blue.
You mean the guys in the crate that are controlling the RC helicopter with the
missiles with like a joystick cruises buddy ice.
Yeah,
ice man.
That's who I'm thinking.
Okay.
I'm thinking of,
that's like the perfect macho fighter pilot with perfect bone structure.
Those guys have like 2010 vision.
They see shit.
You don't see Kevin Pereira,
you're not a sky warrior.
Clearly not know.
What do you do for a living?
I'm a sky.
Whoa.
That's way better than the air force.
She called the Sky Warriors.
Come on.
I'm sure they do.
Internally it's two thousand fifteen thousand bumps in slow mo in the locker
rooms are the sky warriors.
We are legion
some fortunate or just woke up like
I played after burner.
I know what it's like.
I'm
curious as to see what what effect drone technology is going to have on our
overall quality of life over the next few years because as I've seen more and
more of these fucking videos with these things flying around,
I'm like at what point in time is it going to be like commonplace to be go
outside and there's fucking drones all over the place.
Picking things
five years,
five years.
There's going to be dog walking drones.
I think back to the future too.
Back in the future to walking drones.
What do you mean by old name?
Walk your dog.
Snap it.
[inaudible] GPS.
You track the streets and it goes through GPS and finds it.
What if your dog walking a pit bull and he can't hold on to that fucking leash
and it wants to kill something?
It's got emergency jets that only last about 20 minutes that are really strong.
Some sort of tranq dart that'll just shoots into your pooches neck.
You've never had fires and hits the police office.
They'll wait that 20 minutes out,
they'll fight it out and when that 20 minutes is over,
there'll be ready.
They'll still chase that dog pit bulls of the worst though.
The worst when it comes to like dog aggression.
Right.
And I've had him,
I've had dogs that were,
I've had,
you know,
they vary.
I've had a few pit bulls,
some of them when they were really sweet and didn't want to have anything to do
with fighting other dogs.
And then other ones that that's all they wanted to do.
And no matter what you tried to do to get it out of them,
especially males,
that is what they want to do.
And it's,
it's so annoying because like,
it's like having a friend who's super awesome until he gets around other people
and then he starts attacking them and beating the shit out of him.
And you're like,
why would,
why would you do this?
Why are you attacking all of these people?
These people are fucking nice,
but he's like,
fuck is shoe and me.
That's it.
That's how pitfalls are.
When like if other dogs come around,
there's a few of them.
It's not all of them,
but it's,
it,
it.
A lot of it has to do with how they were bred and if you get one that had an
actual lineage of dog fighting,
you know,
you're likely going to hear that.
That DNA is modified years of breeding of now when you come out you get big,
strong fast and you murder well.
The actual scary ones believe it or not or not even that big.
Really?
Yeah.
The real fighting dogs,
the dogs they use in actual like gambling matches are fairly small.
They're like 35 pounds,
like 35 pounds is actually a big one.
Those are pit bulls.
The real pit bulls.
What do you see these big like a muscle bound modified dogs.
These are bred to look good.
Those dogs,
they would never last against one of those little 35 pound dogs.
Cause those 35 pound dogs just don't get tired.
They don't get tired and they don't give up and they don't give a fuck about
pain.
And they don't even look scary.
Like if you look at a real pit bull,
they don't have the super wide head.
They're actually fairly small dogs.
Chess and the definition.
Yeah,
they're fairly small dogs and they're really great with people.
They're the sweetest with people because one of the reasons why they fight is to
please their owner,
right?
Like it's really a crazy relationship.
They're the sweetest,
kindest dogs.
They look so friendly with people.
But sometimes the mistake babies for animals,
you know,
and they're very scary in that way.
Like little kids and babies are,
it's very dangerous to have them around like suit certain super hyper aggressive
dogs.
Cause they don't know if they've never seen a baby before but then never seen a
little kid before.
They might think it's an animal.
Right.
Fuck that.
You know,
fuck all that.
I don't think the drone is gonna be able to hold that back.
What's weird that you could just raise dogs,
you know,
and teach them how to attack this kind of,
I mean,
I get the idea you can have it and abandon them to that.
There's a lot of weird,
that's weird.
That's weird,
right?
But in that we're like,
well,
you know,
it's the question is like if give them up for foster care,
what would it be?
Better to be with the person who wants to give you up to foster girlies with
foster care,
you might have a shot total one trying to,
trying to raise you and love you.
Totally.
You know,
obviously there's a bunch of different reasons why people give people up,
but there's always plan B.
Yeah.
The idea of given up your kid to foster care for no reason other than anything
else.
Like if you're going
to die or you know,
I mean people,
that kind of shit happens and it's great in that sense.
But you all those nightmare stories about foster kids,
it's like
you always have to think how fucked up where they,
when they got in there.
You know?
I mean when you hear about foster parents having to deal with kids that were
just severely abused for large chunks of their life that can go into a puppy
mill.
I want to know that abs for for anything,
any,
any scar I put on an animal.
I want to know.
I put it there.
You know my dog pisses on the carpet when I microwave a hot pocket.
I wanted to ask because I was punching it in the face the first time that
happened.
Not somebody else.
Yeah.
If you get a dog from a really good breeder that it's one thing if someone like
is a very ethical breeder and they're really kind of their dogs,
you're going to likely get a really good dog but you could get a really good dog
at the pound.
Totally.
You never know.
It's like I wonder how much epigenetics and like learned behavior passed down
through the genes like affects dogs and people.
You know like the idea of adopting a kid.
Like people love the idea of adopting kid.
I mean you give someone a fresh start.
I mean that's amazing.
I mean give,
give a baby a chance and you know,
and loving family takes him in or her in.
But you always have to like wonder.
Like I wonder how much of what a person is,
is what you teach them and what they see in their environment and how much of it
is actually in their genetics.
I mean I think for sure you could take someone from a troubled genetic
background and raise them with love and friendship and they could be great
people.
Sure not questioning that.
But what I am questioning is how much of who you are and who your personality
becomes is really based on your genes.
Right.
Don't you know,
I would,
I would really like to know that no matter how much nurture you give somebody,
they might still have a natural proclivity to be addicted to opioids.
It's just like a thing that might happen.
Same with other diseases and mental disorders and who knows?
So you can nurture the hell out of someone.
But at some point when it's,
when those synapses were firing and forming,
even in the womb and you know,
soap opera theme shows are implanting on its brain.
There are studies now that say that even in the womb that early,
you know,
people can,
these messages and memories are in prime planted on the brain.
At some point you pop out and a certain percentage of your path is formed by a
certain percentage of your being is there that's unshakeable and undeniable.
Yeah.
I wonder how much and what that number is.
12 12% 12% seven so that's the over under,
what's the over under?
I think you can nurture,
you can nurture the shit out of most.
Most things.
You can really turn it around at any age.
At any phase.
There's always turnaround stories,
but there are certain,
you know,
we know there are certain genetic markers that mean you're going to be
predisposed to certain things you can do.
No question about it,
no question about it.
Especially when it comes to certain diseases that are just almost unavoidable.
For certain people,
they have to be like really careful about their diet just because their genetics
are set up in a,
you know,
unfortunate.
Why?
Yeah.
That's a strange,
strange thing about being a person,
man.
All the variables and then blaming someone for those variables coming out all
fucked up and them being a mess.
Right.
You know,
you need to take accountability,
pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
That's totally true if you can,
but right way it's way better to like figure out a way to mitigate the amount of
people that are fucked up.
Like instead of like saying you know,
need to pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
Probably.
Yeah,
probably.
But also how the fuck did this happen?
Like why are there,
you know,
x amount of million people living in destitute poverty in Los Angeles.
I mean,
how many people are in like severe poverty in Los Angeles?
What is the percentage?
I wouldn't begin to know the number.
I wouldn't know the number,
but it's probably fairly high.
I bet.
I bet it would be a shocking number.
Let's guess
if they could afford bootstraps,
they might pull them up
stairs.
How many millions are there in Los Angeles?
Like California,
all together as like 20 million or something like that.
All right,
let's,
let's find that out first.
All right.
How many people are in,
okay,
so truck is leaving Chicago.
Yes.
Are we,
are we going like what's unemployment
or what?
Well,
first of all,
how many people live in la?
How many,
how would you guess,
you guess?
17 million.
Okay.
This doesn't make sense cause this only says 3 million.
The Greater Los Angeles area,
which,
uh,
contains three oh 13 million and over 18 million people in combined statistical
area as recently as 2010.
So somewhere around,
let's just call it somewhere around,
uh,
18 million people.
Right?
Fair enough.
So,
uh,
I forgot what we're talking about,
Jack.
We were trying to find out how many people are living in poverty to have that
Jesus Christ.
That's how boring I am.
I bore myself.
Yeah.
Okay.
How many people live in poverty on a photo of a bunch of old dudes fucking and
sucking each other on a hotel bed.
And that's what I've managed to pull up.
What one party,
Bro,
you're not down the line party.
That one's all what line.
Okay,
and party,
right?
Yeah.
Lemon party.
But why did you bring that up?
Because that's what happens when I start typing into a browser.
You're capable,
you're,
you can function and actually solve the problem.
That's all I can do is pull up pictures of old dicks.
That's not true.
I'm not sure what you're trying to say,
but that's not true.
Welcome to my world.
Okay.
I guess I'd employments 19% 27% and in Los Angeles,
27% of all the people in Los Angeles or in poverty and poverty.
Okay.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And so that's insane.
That's a lot of God damn people.
Right?
And there's people that aren't in poverty that have definitely struggled and
worked very hard to not be there.
That immediately assume that the lack of working hard and the lack of a work
ethic is the reason someone who is in poverty is in that case.
You know,
they assume that we are out of work actors though they can't first unemployment.
How many in poverty,
how many of them are out of work actors that you can feel sorry for?
Because if he knew them,
they'd be like really annoying.
Be like,
yeah,
who wants to hire that guy?
I don't know.
Dream chasers.
Uh,
a lot of dream chasers in La,
right?
For sure.
Right.
But I think the point that you were getting at is that it's very easy for
people,
especially in a situation of privilege or one where they're not living paycheck
to paycheck or horror.
Who knows what happened in their past.
Maybe they had a family growing up.
It's very easy for them to think.
We all line up at the starting line at age zero,
the gun goes off and all right.
You just didn't want to run fast enough or hard enough.
It doesn't matter that you started off with one leg or you didn't even,
you weren't even at the the stadium for this race.
You know,
it's,
it's hard for people to empathize and realize that we all start off at different
places and in different ways.
We all think we're running the same race.
Well,
it's also a solid fucking race.
That's the other thing.
It's not,
I mean like if one person makes 10 times more money,
but they're fucking miserable in there constantly.
I have a heart attack.
I'm sure a person makes enough to live and then they're happy.
That guy wins.
Like the guy was making enough to pay his bills and feed himself and is having a
chill life and having fun with his friends.
That guy wins over.
The Guy who never sees his family has a heart attack work 16 hours a day.
He's popping Adderall data.
What if he's got a ski market ski,
do like a sweet ski Doo and he's just fun talking about Russian way.
Really rich dude.
Yeah,
like really rich data that we'll have time to be out there ski doing.
I meant the marathon of life,
not the marathon of,
of money.
You know like that people think we line up and we all are afforded the same
privileges.
So look,
even that guy that makes just enough money and is happy with his friends,
he probably started off in a better place than some others around him because
there's no denying should some people are born into this world without families,
without support systems,
without structure.
And it could be that he came up in a horrible environment if I can get it out
and he got through.
But it doesn't mean that everyone should be forced to figure that out on their
own.
Like the idea of not helping people,
it just seems weird that as a government,
like the government doesn't put more emphasis into that.
You would think like there were constantly worried about conflicts overseas when
constantly worried about conflicts,
you know,
in places where we're never going to go.
But the conflict that's causing murder and our own neighborhoods and cities is
almost like it's the root cause of it is never totally completely addressed like
Chicago,
like what's going on in Chicago with all the insane amounts of murder and
violence and Detroit.
It's obviously got a lot big problems.
He does lots of cities in this country there.
People are dying left and right and it's very likely a direct result of this
crazy infrastructure problem that we have where there's a giant percentage of
people that are living in poverty and until they figure out a way to like sue
that down,
it's going to always fuel those conspiracy theories are people like this is by
plan to government wants everyone to be huddled up together,
angry and fighting over scraps of bread.
You know,
that's the,
that's
the plan.
Like to keep the people week and keep them scared and you know,
bring them into these environments and forced them to compete for very limited
resources to so that they're always fucked up and they never really have a
chance to organize and figure out the system and,
and restructure and create their own.
Come up with her own fucking Krypto currencies,
right?
I,
you know,
the argument that I see all the time is can't give a handout or can't have a
social safety net because someone else is going to take advantage of that and no
one else should be rewarded for being lazy.
And I go,
look,
yeah,
there are certainly cases of that and that exists and it sucks and we should
prosecute those cases violently.
Fuck those people.
Even Violin,
Limu,
I mean with,
with passion,
not violently,
but like with passionate people get crazy with their violence and passion.
Yeah.
It's the same thing,
Joe,
to same thing.
I'm punching her.
It's out of extreme passion.
Christ son much settled down,
so it's easy to go,
hey,
I don't want anybody taking advantage of me.
How dare you be lazy and suckle from the government t whatever else.
It's very easy to understand your neighbor taking advantage of you,
right?
You work hard,
you come home,
you see your neighbor not working as hard,
how dare he get any leg up.
But the real abuse,
the real systemic abuse in the real fleecing is happening at such a,
at the corporate and political level in such a great way that it's so hard for
us,
I think for many to wrap their brains around.
And it's a lot easier to point to the,
the abuse and the laziness of a neighbor and not the abuse of,
of uh,
of a government.
Yeah,
that's,
that is absolutely true.
And it's also one of those things,
like we were talking about earlier with the cops enforcing the law,
if that's the system that's in place,
that system's fucked up.
Like ethically,
people understand that the amount of money that was moved around during that
whole collapse in the economy and the amount of money that was moved around
during the wars,
well,
during the,
during the wars for sure.
I mean they're,
they're finding there's something like 50,000 troops are like ghosts.
They're not really people and they're somehow or another,
these 50,000 people are getting checks.
And you know,
who knows where the fuck that's going.
Either it's complete waste and incompetence or someone's like filtering off that
money somehow and putting it somewhere and sure using it for some,
there's always stories.
Billions unaccounted for,
trillions of dollars unaccounted for,
all this corruption thing all day they get vehicles and they burned them so they
can order more because then they get to skim off the top.
Like there's story after story of this happening and when you talk about
Chicago,
you know what helped there.
But some schools maybe,
maybe a community garden,
who knows some music,
get up,
get the kid's a fucking Tuba and a teacher that's compensated to,
to teach them how to use it.
That doesn't cost trillions and trillions of dollars per sure.
And you know,
it's also when we were talking about earlier with quotas,
like quotas sort of put a machine in place.
Yes,
almost make it where it's to their benefit to continue to allow a certain amount
of crime so they could continue to have certain amount of people that they
arrest.
And it's almost like that with when you have gigantic corporations that
contribute money towards towards candidates that they know it would be more
likely to engage in military conflict.
You know,
and we've seen,
you've seen direct results of relationships between these gigantic corporations
like Hal Haliburton or you know,
that's the even rapid scan getting these scanners in.
It's an offshoot of the,
of the war.
There's just so much money involved and that money's been going back and forth
through these people for so long.
It almost becomes impossible to stop because it's like,
hey,
we're going to come along and tell you that you can't make $1 billion a year
anymore,
and then you're going to go,
no,
fuck that.
I make $1 billion everywhere.
This is what I do.
I make $1 billion every year.
They go,
no,
no.
You're not going to make $1 billion anymore because what you're doing,
we're not going to let you do anymore.
We're going to make it illegal.
What?
Illegal to kill people in another country to make $1 billion.
Dude,
how am I going to make $1 billion if I can't kill people in another country?
I need to make tanks and I make fucking jets that shoot rockets I need to make
does money.
New Granite counter in my 12 home.
Yep.
In the Hamptons.
People don't ever want to downsize.
No.
They want to push further.
You know?
So like if a guy's,
what stock is celebrated for maintaining none.
No Shit.
That that grass needs to go up.
That's what did the stocks,
yeah.
Businesses have this weird thing like they want to make more money every year
and that's,
I mean,
I guess that's the deal with inflation that every year the money's not worth as
much or more money is,
but still,
no,
you want
bigger house?
I want a bigger car.
I'll fuck up,
up,
up.
Can I move up in this world?
Jetson,
you know,
like people get crazy.
I need music.
Reactive LEDs in my pussy at home.
We need to restructure.
Society got damn and Kevin Prayer.
You need to run for government here.
Joe Rogan.
It starts right here.
Are you ready to run for government?
Are you ready to be a president?
Skeletons yet.
Oh,
I have many,
but I've let most of them out myself,
but cowboy hats on them and bring them around,
but you know,
government isn't where you could make a change like that.
Unfortunately,
you're buying into a system where you're beholden to fundraising,
which then you're beholden to the people who gave you that money.
I have
a feeling that the way the technology of the world is progressing,
like we have this idea,
follow me on this.
Yup.
We have this idea that the law that's in place now as far as the laws that are
in place,
like how fast you can drive and what's legal and what's illegal.
These are all in place and enforced in a system that we have all agreed to.
We've all agreed to this system because it's been in place for a long time.
There's the firemen,
there's the policemen.
These are iconic figures.
I know the colors of their vehicles.
This is a regular part of our culture,
but as the Internet expands and we start wearing these head pieces that can
communicate with each other through Wifi and and send thoughts from brain to
brain,
which they've already proved they can do over the Internet.
Correct.
We're going to get to a point,
we're going,
why is this system place?
Why do we need the system?
This system is just,
you're,
you're saying you're in charge and I'm saying the people that said someone could
be in charge.
We're from a totally different world.
Okay?
They weren't even from,
they're not even from Earth.
They're from earth 1776 and there was nothing going on then.
Okay.
You add a pasture and you're shooting bows and arrows and animals to try to stay
alive.
You're growing some fruits and vegetables.
You're building a boat in case you got to get the fuck Outta here of some other
people show up and they have cannons pointing in your direction and you're
living in an incredibly simple world.
The world of today.
I would,
I would say there's a good deal of what is going on in the world today,
especially in terms of what kind of communications we're able to pass back and
forth to each other.
What kind of information we're able to spread and what,
what kind of messages and interactions you can get from,
which is this giant,
giant,
giant group of people like worldwide and like people can agree or disagree or be
outraged or or or or be be kind and sensitive like all of it can happen in these
big giant waves going over like a whole planet that's,
this is a different time.
The whole thing's different and as soon as we figure out a way to to interface
with each other like completely and totally all the time,
we're going to have to rethink like a lot of the laws that we have in place,
the lot of the laws of don't we're going to like,
wow,
why is this law still around?
Because someone's profiting from it.
Is that what we're doing,
where we've set up these situations where we have a steady stream of money
coming in that you guys are addicted to.
So because you guys are addicted,
this money,
you're going to put like 16 year old kids in jail because they're selling
joints.
Are you gonna you're gonna,
you're gonna take people that are doing things that they should absolutely have
the right to do.
If you can buy cigarettes,
if you can drive a motorcycle,
if you can fill in the blank,
there's a million fucking dangerous things that we allow on a regular basis.
But you're telling that kid he can't have mushrooms,
right?
Because what?
Because you say so.
Fuck you.
Who are you?
Have you ever done mushrooms?
Why?
Why are you saying he can't do it?
This is our problem.
Our problem is our system is archaic.
It's not caught up to,
to who we are as human beings today.
It's not cut up to the way we interact with each other.
It's just not this idea of a representative government where I can represent
myself so you can represent yourself too.
This isn't 18 six in fucking Philadelphia where you had to get a guy and pick up
your handwritten scrawl on some fucking shitty piece of paper and put your stamp
on it and hand it to him and he writes right a fucking horse into town and
deliver it to other people.
It's different fucking world.
I don't need a representative government.
We represent each other.
The more segmented that we get,
the more like the smaller everything shrinks down.
We should all be in charge of our own thoughts.
Okay?
And if we all vote a popular for the entire United States and it comes out all
fucked up and things go chaotic,
guess what that means?
You engineered a system where half the people are fucking retarded,
guaranteed.
And this is what happens when you do that.
This is what happens when you don't take advantage of the number one resource
human beings have,
which is other human beings you don't like.
Pump these people up and try to make them productive members of society that are
competing alongside of everyone else and,
and,
and producing alongside of everyone else and interacting and being a part of
communities.
No,
you just say,
just leave them in their little shitty spot and fuck them.
And when you do that,
if you actually have a common vote,
have you ever had actually have a popular vote?
You're going to deal with a huge number of uneducated people.
A huge number of disenfranchised people that grew up in fucked up households,
crazy fucking parents and drugs and meth and fucking how many are that?
It's millions and millions.
And they could vote.
Everyone can vote,
everyone can vote.
Have you got a popular vote?
You got a real fucking problem.
And that has to be one of the things that they were thinking of when they made
this whole electoral college system.
And you know,
they,
when they,
when they created like a representative government,
they had to let go on.
Can't just like,
everybody can't just have a vote.
It's still too crazy.
It's too crazy.
You know?
I agree.
I don't know that that was,
that was for a nefarious reasons.
I mean at the time just the technology alone for that wouldn't have happened.
I mean they would still be counting votes were by hand and by candle light,
but I think if they did allow for a popular vote it was probably problematic.
Even back then you had a lot of apes,
you know like these motherfuckers are going to get to get what we need is one
dude.
We can really trust that he gets to say what the fuck and state's going to do as
in Doug's edge.
Edumacated get him in there and he won't speak for us.
It's a total illiterate June of of a choice.
Cause he me,
you kind of had a choice but you only have a choice to get to choose who chooses
for you,
which is crazy.
Right?
It's,
I'm on not a baby,
it's 2014 I'm not a baby.
But also he looked the to play devil's advocate,
the amount of time and energy and resources that you,
that that any of us would have to devote to paying attention to everything
that's coming down the pipe politically,
legislatively,
what,
however you want to look at it.
It would be a full time job for all of us to be,
to be well reasoned and well educated on all issues.
So I do see the merit in having someone appointed to maybe advise you to give
you an opinion on something,
but at the end of the day,
if I want to cast a vote,
I should directly be able to do that.
If I'm not there,
you do it on my behalf.
Well,
we need to do first and foremost is all laws which are in place that don't
involve a victim,
right?
Morality laws,
St Long victimless crime,
all laws that pertain to you deciding what you can and cannot do with your own
person,
your body,
your mind,
where you live,
all those things,
all those laws should be taken off the books.
Like let's just start from scratch because that,
those are ridiculous.
You got admitted all these crazy drug laws.
If you could go buy
prescription drugs at any pharmacy or your doctor can,
you could say,
Hey,
I've got this issue,
blah,
blah.
Your doctor decides you need some pain pills you bought.
I don't know how many they give you.
They give you a 30 they give you a month's worth.
Maybe you have to take two a day.
Maybe they give you 60 just swallow all 60 of them with a bottle of whiskey and
you're dead.
Okay?
Everyone can do that.
So if that's the case,
you can't decide what other shit people can't do.
You can't.
You're not allowed to because you haven't made any sense because the choices
that you've allowed that you have tax stamps on their murderous,
they kill hundreds of thousands of people,
whether it's cigarettes or alcohol,
standing on moral quicksand like you're sinking,
you talking crazy.
I know that you're being bought and paid for and you can't run everybody.
If you're clearly being bought and paid for that,
you can't do that.
Now what happens when you say like,
listen,
and some places it's still illegal to have anal sex still is.
It's amazing.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
But the act of it or the fact that it's illegal,
both,
right.
The fact that it's illegal,
it's the,
the,
the horrible.
So,
so now it becomes illegal and you say,
well,
there's no,
there's no victims.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to consent.
That's great.
So what happens when I go to the park?
And two people are just exploiting it.
They are raw dogging as hard as they can.
And Nick to the seesaw.
Now,
am I a victim in this or is this there?
Or is this their freedom of expression?
Okay.
Is it their right to be able to fuck wherever?
Because we would've been able to when we were sitting by,
you know,
campfires and living in caves.
That's a very good point.
You know,
I mean seen you draw the line
in that sense,
community should be able to decide what they accept and they don't accept in
their community where it may possibly,
um,
uh,
what's the best way
or to use,
because in that case,
I'm going right up to the county line and I'm fucking everything that I can just
across the border so the kids can see it when they're getting out of school.
Illegal in my town.
Sorry,
kids.
I don't know if it will work.
Probably think of,
see it,
it's probably still illegal.
Probably had rules though,
but I was trying to figure out what you think.
So,
yeah,
I don't think so.
I think everybody's fucking say that that would be a,
a law.
The,
the way you could say that you could,
you'd have a victim there is cause you expose people to very uncomfortable
things that the,
you don't necessarily have to do.
Like you're imposing upon them.
The visual image and the act of something with a lot of people think is grody.
So as a,
as a,
as a staunch Vegan Joe Rogan,
I'm offended when I see that Hunka red meat on the plate at the restaurant and
I'm walking by and it's on the street.
So no more steaks on curbside.
You gotta be inside.
You can't have a stake in the afternoon.
I bet there's people who would argue that.
Right.
It's crazy that there are,
there are certain hardcore vegans that probably are very angry when they walk by
a restaurant and they see plates of meat outside.
They're a pita members that don't want to see your dogs on a leash because you
shouldn't own an animal.
Yeah.
Dare you.
Well,
that's the animal liberation people.
Those,
those people are off the charts.
Sure.
Oh,
there's some panel members that also,
do we know about that?
About the lobster folks know what's the lobster [inaudible] lobster liberation
people with claws?
No,
no,
no.
These people break into the restaurants,
get lobsters and paste them in the ocean.
Yes,
they do.
They kick open like the front door to the red lobster and go to the aquarium in
the lobby and just started yanking them out.
They go to sea food stores and the break in the middle of the night and steal
all the lobsters out of their tanks and then release them in the,
it's gotta be a fetish right there.
Fucking something going on there.
Are you ever had a claw job?
You were trying really hard today.
You never had one.
I'll let you answer that.
Do you think I've had a claw job?
No.
Joe Rogan.
I don't think you have.
And that's why I don't think you're in a position to judge anyone on it.
So how about that,
what they're doing then?
They're not raping the lobsters there,
there liberating them.
They really,
uh,
they really liberating lobster here in lies the issue when you propose the
Utopia of,
let me vote for me.
Let me have a say.
It's a victimless crime because everybody at some point Topia for everybody to
get a choice.
Isn't that seem crazy?
That that's utopia.
That's what I mean.
That's what was being proposed as right.
Like this is even a start,
a better story,
a better,
better place,
but someone's always going to feel victimized for sure.
Always.
Oh,
for sure.
So how do you police that?
Well,
I think,
here's,
here's my thoughts on it.
One of the big ones is if everything did go to popular vote and we would really
like this.
A recent Gallup poll,
one of the crazier ones,
it was something in the neighborhood of 40 something percent of people believe
the earth is less than 10,000 years old.
People that they polled,
you know,
they believe in the biblical account of the Earth.
When you have a giant number of people in this country,
a giant number that are growing up,
as we said,
in poverty or in,
you know,
in crime ridden neighborhoods in,
in areas where they're not getting a lot of education or the not getting a lot
of positive role models and there's just millions and millions of people that
perpetuate the same sort of cycle.
If you have a popular vote there,
can I get the phone?
It's going to be crazy.
Everyone's going to get the vote.
So the those millions can like,
they can sway a politician one way or other.
So there's politicians that would purposely try to keep people ignorant.
There's politicians that will purposely play to people's ignorance like forget
about what if you just release it as a popular vote.
The world like we're going to realize like we have a fucked up balance of how
many people are impoverished,
how many people in an educated,
how many people have no hope?
There's a fucked up balance.
If that balance doesn't get addressed.
Like if you had something like an Internet vote where everyone gets to vote
online,
you know you'll,
everyone has their own device.
You all vote.
It's ever,
it's like an APP.
You,
you get on your phone,
everybody can get it.
Sure.
Pretty much.
You know everybody's got a cell phone or someone they know at least to have an
internet connection and worldview.
Sure.
You do it like that.
No.
If you looked at the world,
you can go to other countries,
man.
I mean a good percentage of people.
There's more cell phones on earth right now than there are humans.
But that's mostly because like,
you know,
some people have four phones to one house.
That's still an incredible number.
When you consider there's seven goddamn billion people on this planet and those
numbers,
man,
I mean that's,
we're talking,
that's,
this is,
this is like a crazy amount of human beings.
If every one,
three,
all 350 million,
you know,
everyone over 18,
whenever that is,
200 million,
whatever the number is,
if all those people got to vote,
like on everything,
on everything we decide and all sorts of options were on the table,
not just democratic for options versus Republican options,
you know,
of a PR representative or a president.
But everything we do,
everything we do from reparations for slavery,
how about that gets introduced.
How about they want,
uh,
African Americans to get money?
The same way American Indians get money.
American Indians that are forced to live on reservations,
a lot of times they get money,
right?
Like people that live in Alaska,
they get money from the oil companies.
They get like a check.
If you're an Alaska resident,
they get like a check every month,
so there's going to be like votes like,
Hey,
okay,
well how come you have money that goes to people in Alaska and you got money for
people over here?
Why don't we give money to black people?
Verizon put in a fake tree cell phone tower two blocks from my house,
which I'm sure has given me all sorts of cancers,
which will show up in a few years' time and there was a city hall meeting about
it.
Not a vote,
but they had a meeting about it.
That tower goes up,
they're going to make some money off that.
Right.
It's going to serve as customers.
It's directly affecting me.
I didn't have a say and my bill's not going down because they're allowed to
expand.
It's that that kind of should,
I would love to have a say on,
but then you look at local elections,
look at the cycle that we just had here where you know,
half the population didn't vote at all.
Yeah.
They had the ability to on issues that affected them,
but they didn't.
It's not that easy to move either,
man.
If you wanted to get out of your place,
you don't have to sell it and trust someone fucking house today and not losing
money market as goofy as fuck.
It's all confusing.
Like how much is the house worth?
You know,
if you really stop and think about how much,
how much people's houses cost.
Like have you ever been to places where the houses are extremely overvalued?
If you ever been in California,
most shorts.
Yeah.
Have you ever been to like the bay area?
Like silicone from there?
Yeah.
Okay.
That is a crazy place to be now.
And there's all these stories that are being written on San Francisco at about
how many tech millionaires are moving up there and the prices of things are just
crazy high.
Like a regular house is like $2 million,
two point $3 million and you go,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
They were trying to explain to me when I was up there,
this guy was pointing at this house,
said that house sold for three and a half million dollars and I'm like,
you're crazy.
That's not real.
It's a real tear down,
but when they build something new on it,
it'll be great.
No,
it was a nice house.
It was a nice house.
Was in normal looking nice house,
but it was a small like regular house.
It wasn't a three and a half million dollar house.
It was like like a $500,000.
Sure.
It was a nice,
that's a nice house.
You can get a nice house for $500,000 and I was like,
what?
How?
How has that work?
I don't demand supply and demand.
Like how many people are billionaires up here?
Like what kind of a crazy hive of cash is up in that spot?
All has having to do with technology.
Oh,
having to do with the Internet.
All having to do with future advances like Tesla Motors,
shit like that.
They're
all up there.
Yeah.
All those fucking Google people.
They're all up there.
That's what you pay the price to be in that vicinity.
You pay the price to be near those engineers and those venture capitalists and
those angel investors do.
That's what you're buying into as the proximity.
I have a friend who's renting a house in Atherton.
The house,
the house is worth like $15 million.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's just a regular house.
It's a regular fucking house,
but you go in the yard and the yard is pretty big,
so it's worth like $15 million.
So I'm like,
that is the craziest fucking thing I've ever heard in my life.
Have you been down to snow set,
Santa Monica Silicon beach now as they're rebranding it?
Same thing's happening.
Well,
Venice as well,
Callan sold his place in Venice.
He sold it in one day and he made money off of it.
He's like,
Google is like opening up some thing down in Venice.
So they're just buying up property.
These crazy millionaire fucking ones and zero people come into town moneybag it
up.
You have,
you hate that?
No,
I don't hate it.
I love the fact that they create technology right.
I mean,
I don't hate the fact that they're getting Richie cause that's where the
headsets coming from.
That's how we're all going to communicate coming from you or I sir.
No,
I mean I have no problem with,
I've,
I'm just fascinated by trends and I'm absolutely fascinated by,
I don't like the fact that people who,
uh,
make a moderate amount of money or being pushed out of neighborhoods that bums
me out,
especially people that have had friends grow up in that neighborhood and they,
you know,
the kids go to school and the neighborhood and they're being pushed out because
houses are becoming extremely expensive.
Right.
Which is unfortunately a big problem and a big byproduct of this whole tech
boom,
you know,
money grab,
it's like these,
these are so many people up there that are making so much money.
It's like way more than we could ever wrap our heads around.
You know,
like there's like a bunch of billionaires up there like a gang of them
and we say billion and we think we can fathom that.
Like,
Oh yeah,
I get a billion.
Sure.
But you can imagine that in monopoly money,
not none of us know what $1 billion.
Truly like the notion that you could not spend enough money fast enough,
nobody goes,
oh,
of course I could.
I'd blow up space station.
Yeah.
You literally couldn't spend money fast enough before you died to spend all the
money you have.
Yeah.
It wasn't until it's unfathomable.
It would literally wouldn't be physically possible.
I know some billionaires,
it's very weird.
Even when I'm around him I get nervous
too rich.
It's too rich.
It's weird.
What pay grade or you come like most comfortable around.
I like where do you hold that make around a hundred grand a year.
That sounds pretty solid list.
Yeah,
like hundred grands.
Like you could pay your bills but you're not getting crazy.
Right.
You know,
it's like when they get into that keeping up with the Joneses level,
when they get into the millions,
when you start making a lot of money,
especially,
uh,
I think if you're like one of those Wall Street cats,
you're dealing with a bunch of other people around you that you're trying to
keep up with.
Well there Brian houses in the Hamptons and you're buying,
you know,
they're buying the s five 50 and you know,
and like,
Whoa,
I've got to keep up.
And I think they get trapped in that sort of,
uh,
keeping up with the Joneses and they becomes everything that that becomes the
reward
for,
for extracting ones and zeroes.
So it's all about making more see more success.
You know,
dog eat dog,
you know,
go for the jugular and then get the,
get the house that shows you got the higher level of what'd that fucking goofy
game you're playing destiny.
It's their version of desks that,
but I'll let it slide,
but they have a house in the Hamptons,
she shouldn't present it.
It's a real,
their version of tyrosine has anything.
Why is it,
why was that goofy game?
It's really,
it's a phenomenal game and level raids.
I love you,
but if you're a goofy man,
here's,
here's the thing.
It's not a bad to be goofy.
I'm goofy as fuck.
You know?
I think at that point the,
the,
when a bank balance defines you,
it's like,
it's not like they're,
they're just amassing this cause they have this greedy pit and they wanted in
greed,
greed.
I think it's actually more human than that.
I think it's,
I've,
I've tried to look at those that have,
that,
that are in the game for extreme wealth for shifting one's and zero's solely in
their favor.
Um,
I feel sorry for them because I feel like that's what defines them and wouldn't
we all like to be the best version of ourselves that we could be.
And for those people sometimes I think that that's,
they think that that's the best version of them is the wealthiest version of
them.
I also think it's very convenient to feel sorry for them because like everyone
in life,
there's a giant spectrum.
So there must be amongst super ball or billionaires,
a dune who is having a fucking blast,
whose life should be a movie,
who's kind and friendly and considerate,
but is just banging tens in his yacht all over the planet.
Like,
whew,
the guys just live in the most crazy,
ridiculous,
fun,
loving party ever and he happens to be like a super successful entrepreneur
slash businessman character.
It's gotta be Ilan [inaudible] possible that someone could be that person,
but we don't associate that associate that.
We always assume that if someone is successful,
if he is some Rolls Royce driving,
look at my mansion,
look at all of my property,
I've got with zero money down and Dan girls are behind them dancing.
We assume that guy's a piece of shit,
right?
We always do.
We always assume that anybody who becomes like stupid Uber,
like private jet successful,
you know,
we always assume that they're assholes,
right?
They must be.
There's no way he could be that like Richard Branson is the only guy.
People go,
man,
I don't know.
He seems cool and want to love them,
but it seems cool.
Richard Branson seems cool.
He's got the long hair.
He says nice things.
He donates a lot of money.
He's got like a lot of charitable causes.
He's got a lot of like interesting philanthropic causes.
Interesting prospects in terms of technology involved in the whole virgin space
flight.
Tolling.
Yeah.
I mean he's a baller.
He's a super billionaire guy,
but he's Kinda nice like,
no,
who's hating Annette?
You're Branson.
He seems like a sweet dude.
Like he's like the best example of what could be possible if someone was like
some super baller capitalists,
but it's like really kind of Nice and chill.
Right?
He was in that fucking high movie man.
Branson was,
yes.
Nice.
Yes.
He did an interview in the culture high about marijuana.
I saw a tweet the tweet the other day about,
we love possession laws.
What the fuck?
Come on guys.
I'm like,
yeah,
good.
He doesn't have to worry about that at his level.
Exactly.
Fuck yeah.
Richard Branson's down.
He's like the coolest billionaire ever.
One of them,
I think he Lorenzo for teens,
musket billionaire by now for Tito.
The guys who own the UFC,
they're pretty fucking cool.
Yeah.
Those guys are billionaires.
They're the only billionaires I feel comfortable around.
They're really friendly.
Like Franklin.
Lorenzo always been like super cools made the guys who own the UFC there,
they're billionaires.
They don't like 20 something casinos.
I think 22 Jesus fucking Christ.
Think about that in Vegas specifically are around the country or I don't know.
I never counted,
but uh,
I think most of them are in Vegas,
but because all those station casinos,
they own all those [inaudible] there's a level of money that you,
certain people get to where it's clear that they're competing with a very small
group of other assholes that are making stupid amounts of money to like the
Forbes high score list.
Yeah.
Got To get number 12.
You know what I look at every year?
I look at like the most expensive yachts.
Like yachts are crazy.
I can't fucking bully Elan Musk.
Yeah,
he's in the bill.
1.1 billion on paper.
Yesterday.
Yeah.
Just yesterday.
You made a million over the last,
um,
oh my God.
Deserves every penny.
I know what happened,
uh,
as shares any tests has motors gained nearly 14%.
So yeah,
but that could go away tomorrow.
That's fluctuating.
That's not fair.
That's kind of sneaky.
Those sneaky fucking numbers play an asshole cylinder.
If he decides to cash out today.
It's real.
Yeah,
that is true.
It's real.
It's very real money.
He's not going to,
but I forgot my point.
What I'm curious about what I was talking about.
You said some billionaires make you uncomfortable.
Have you been in the room with a billionaire who said something or done
something?
[inaudible]
babies,
but that's normal.
That's what everybody does mean.
Did they marinate over that 48% tax bracket?
Is there any barbecue sauce or would they just,
oh no,
I've met,
I've met quite a few over my years of working for the UFC.
And um,
I think the weird thing about human beings is yos expect while these people are
going to be fucking different,
you know,
I've met royal people,
I've met royalty in a,
especially in the Arab Emirates,
United Arab Emirates,
and a normal regular folks.
Like I talk to them,
super friendly,
super normal.
I know a dude who's,
you know,
he's a royalty and he listens to my podcast,
like gets weird shit.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
But when you're around him after like a minute,
you forget that he's a royalty in wants talk MMA,
right.
And then wants to talk techniques,
wants to talk.
Uh,
you know,
what happened with that?
Why did this go wrong?
What do you think his prospects are like?
Dudes like a super fan.
So we have these awesome like technical conversations about strategies and
stuff.
Can I choke him with diamonds and rings?
Can I put faithful the bombing in his mouth?
Cause I do.
I have large rope.
Gold Rope.
Yeah.
Get in nick,
good in octagon.
Eileen,
Eileen chopper on him.
By the way,
I,
you must have,
I know you have analytics so you know how many people listened to your podcast,
but in your heart of hearts,
do you really understand the reach that your voice has on a weekly basis?
It's insane.
No,
I think,
no,
I think it's fucking beautiful,
man.
I was,
I went on a Iowaska journey.
I was in Iquitos,
Peru and I have the 20 some odd people there.
I texted you while I was there saying,
hey man,
every fucking morning your name comes up over eggs.
And,
and lentils,
like people are taught,
like you drew people there from all over the world at all ages,
all walks of life,
all coming there based off of hearing you interview people and talk about this
and I was buying too disavow
all knowledge of you bring up this subject.
I didn't know that this is going to be discussed.
I would have spoken with my attorney.
I believe what those people are doing is illegal.
Uh,
that's why I haven't done it for real.
It's one per room to be clear in our country.
I think someone was actually trying to pass a law saying that if you violate a
law outside of America,
can't talk about it and no,
but that's an American law.
You can be tried for it in America.
God,
I forget the particulars.
I hate when I do that.
But it was so bizarre because someone was saying that it would be in protection
of children having like going over and having like sex with a child.
Prostitutes.
I'm heading to Bora Bora.
Yeah,
you're going to 12 year olds now.
I'm counting the fort back here.
Exactly.
You could be [inaudible] as a pedophile and a rapist in America.
But then people said,
but yeah,
but you could apply those to drug laws.
So you go to Portugal and smoke weed all day and then I'd come back to America
and you arrest me or go to Peru and have an IOWASCA ceremony.
I want ask a sneaky though,
dude,
because it's not technically illegal.
It's in a weird classification cause it's not really die trip to me.
What it is is a brew of a bunch of plants that are all legal.
All those plants are illegal.
You know,
you could buy most of the ingredients for Iowasca online because it's legal.
Correct.
They're not.
There's too much DMT out there and plants to make every plant that has DMT in it
illegal.
So you could conceivably come up with some form of all IOWASCA is all you're,
you're making is an orally active version of DMT,
DMT,
which has been proven to be produced in the human brain.
Your lungs produce it,
your liver produces it.
It's incredibly potent psychedelic drug that your body makes.
And unfortunately it's in everything.
It's in so many different plants and vegetables that our body has ways of
dealing with it.
And one of the ways is this stuff called Mano aiming oxidase is the long and
boring version of it,
but your body produces model Amy [inaudible] days and it destroys DMT when
you're digesting it orally.
But if you take it with what's called harming,
which is unnatural Mao inhibitor,
it becomes this crazy drug that you can drink.
So you can get an orally active DMT trip,
but that's not totally illegal.
But DMT is elite,
right?
You have extracted that is illegal,
but if you have the plants,
that's fine.
It's so funny.
It's like the,
the,
the gun analog is that an ar 15 is illegal in the state of California.
You can't buy one.
Right?
Right.
But you can certainly fucking build one.
Yeah.
It's really easy to do.
There are whole communities built around that where once you have it,
it's okay to have exactly.
Because you made it,
there's a loophole for Ya.
So it's like fuck.
It's like the,
the component is illegal,
but the sum of all the parts is totally fine.
Yeah.
Very weird know.
There's a lot of weird laws,
man.
There's a lot of weird laws.
I was at the shot show two years ago and I saw that like,
cause we will explain what the shots are.
Shot show is comic con for law enforcement.
It is,
it is,
you know Ted Nugent,
they're selling fucking beef,
beef,
Ben Venison Jerky and flaming bow and arrows and guys selling kits to modify or
dodge Durango.
So you can hide three weapons in the center console during Avn.
Awesome.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's a law enforcement and adult superstars.
It's enforcement and what they've created
and uh,
they're babies.
You know,
I went,
I went to this booth that allows you a rude,
I say that twice.
So they sold a piece of a,
of an ar.
Basically it was a bolt on for,
for a,
a a semiautomatic weapon that if you do,
if you held the trigger or held this handle with enough force and held down the
trigger,
the natural recoil of the rifle would automatically chamber the next round and
fire it.
So it turned a non assault rifle or non automatic weapon into one.
And it could retrofit all these guns.
And they were,
you know,
they had a big banner that said California friendly.
Come on guys,
legal and good old CA.
And that was a real rude awakening for the whole,
well I think we need,
we need stricter gun laws and we need some,
some we need to get down on paper exactly what you can and can't own and wine.
It's like,
no,
they'll just figure out a way to make it limbo under whatever legal bar you set
and it's done game over.
Well,
we've got to really figure out a way,
keep mentally ill people from getting guns.
Right.
You know,
and make sure that they do like the people that have guns,
have them locked somewhere.
You have to have it locked.
You can't have it so you're crazy.
Son can come home and raid your gun cabinet.
Like the Newtown,
Connecticut thing.
That's what happened.
Right.
It was like the guy rated his mom's guns or something like that.
I don't remember the exact story,
but it wasn't his,
but you got to make it harder to get them and you got to make sure that we have
a good account,
like a good audit of all the crazy people who can figure out how crazy they are.
How can it be harder to adopt a pet in certain places?
Like there's home inspections and background checks and all sorts of,
it's harder to get an animal than it is to get weapons in certain areas of this
country.
A car drive a car.
Sure.
You have to take a license to drive a car.
It's difficult.
Like kids freak out,
they're panicking.
Then make sure they come to a complete stop,
look left look right.
You know,
but a gun.
There you go.
My pappy used is Corolla for hunting,
so God dammit,
I deserve to be able to drive one if he hands it to me.
This is a video of it.
You have a
dude hitting a deer,
his bike,
he's riding his bike down a hill,
like going pretty fast.
And this deer just perfectly t bones,
I'm or he teens and deer.
And it goes flying and the most uncomfortable part is the end.
The hear him moaning like after he hits,
the guy's like,
oh,
and you know,
Oh,
poor pastor was that.
That was the end of them.
I don't know if he dies.
I think he just got fucked up.
I mean,
you hit a deer on your bike and you're going 30 something miles an hour or
whatever the hell he was going.
He went flying.
It'll collapse in escolade.
So imagine that on your little bike.
Yeah.
Big One can,
right?
There's some big ones too,
man.
Especially in the north,
you know you can,
you could hit one that's like 200 plus pounds.
Did every,
were you hunting where you were up hunting something in the news recently,
weren't you Canada?
Yeah,
I shot a moose with,
what were the rifle now?
Shit.
That's the head over there.
Oh,
that's,
that's there.
That's it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Did you use,
did you say like a sweet eighties action film line before you pulled the
trigger?
No,
I did not.
I did not have much time.
We saw it coming out of the woods or walking through the woods.
We had a small area where could shoot it or even some sort of bluff or where we
were.
We were actually just coming down this road and we saw it on the side of the
road.
It was just total dumb luck.
Wow.
Yeah.
Moose hunting is a tricky thing to do unless they're in the Rut,
which means unless they're breathing,
if they're breathing,
you can kind of find them.
You can call the man.
But we got there a little late so they were done breeding,
so we had to literally just walk around and drive around and try a shot,
a load and he was doing the lazy wattle most likely to get a sandwich.
Most likely he was walking around because he was still looking for some postal.
He was a few guys.
It was three.
I am at the nightclub.
He was that goose.
He's the last call most cause there is a few of them that were fighting.
We've found this dust up in the middle of a street or a dirt road.
Rathers would say that definitely not street.
There was no,
no,
nothing was paved up there.
But um,
these,
uh,
there was like hair everywhere.
Tufts for a little bit of blood and like this big scuffle in the middle.
And you can tell by looking at it that these two giant Moose had just started
smashing heads together.
They were like claiming this area.
And so like all around,
you know,
this huge like patch of dirt,
which salt fucked up with hair and dirt.
And imagine being there while that's going on and you can cue sticks and
Barstools I was like,
fuck you man,
you're dealing with my dirt patch.
1400 pound animals often.
And they have like what looks like a giant saloon door growing off the side of
their head.
And then there's slamming,
slamming the saloon doors into each other.
I mean they have fucking giant trees growing out of their head and they're
smashing into each other with these things.
And these things are huge and if you want,
they're like way bigger than a horse.
They like tower of a horse.
They're really long legged.
Like when we saw one walk across the road,
we were on the,
on this,
um,
this,
uh,
this one road and uh,
like in it was all snowy,
but up ahead like around the corner,
like out steps,
something that is impossibly big,
just way bigger than the truck that we're in.
Like,
wait,
like if we had hit it,
the top of the truck would have smashed into the bottom of the Moose.
Like that's how big it was.
There were enormous,
they don't even look real.
Like if you didn't know Moose was real and it was like a legendary creature and
then you were driving down the road and you saw one walked cross,
it would affect the rest of your life.
You'd be like,
I can't believe I saw a moose.
I thought they were legendary.
I thought it was like a fucking Unicorn.
Oh,
Unicorn.
Get one who are in the middle of his head.
He's magic.
Get the fuck Outta here.
That thinks stupid.
That's a terrible place for a horn.
Looked at this thing.
This thing has giant paddles.
These huge tree branches growing off the side of his head.
You wouldn't believe it was real.
You would think you'd seen some hobbit shit.
You'd seen some Lord of the rings thing.
You know some,
it was like it really like a game of Thrones animals on a real animal.
Giant Moose does.
Big fucking forest horse just wanders across the road.
So do you have to stop and just wait for it to cross because there's nothing,
I mean,
oh yeah.
I mean you don't want to hit it for sure.
Of course you want to hit,
yeah.
You don't want to just,
I wonder if they're not clear.
Let's go here.
Not Smart.
I mean they will fuck up.
Especially when they're horny.
Apparently they,
they try to fuck everything when they're born.
They'll come over and try to fuck a lawn mower.
Like they,
they hear things,
they cried towards those things.
I want to know what the fuck it is and they'll smash you to,
if you get in the way of them and they're horny,
they'll just fucking smash you with those horns and stomp you to jazz's.
Yeah,
they're huge.
I guess I would,
robotic fuck police force is not going to work in Canada.
When we were up there,
we found one that had been taken out by a wolf that was pretty eerie.
A wolf took down a giant ass mouth.
It was a smaller one.
It's a smaller Moose.
It was a bit like a baby moose,
but even a baby moose,
it's like a deer,
like a couple hundred pounds.
I mean it's a big fucking animal and it was just torn apart.
It just,
most of the meat was picked off the bones and you've got there and it wasn't
that long ago.
We had gotten there like maybe a day after it happened,
so it was really eerie to be around this cause you,
there's hair everywhere.
Like I'll show you a picture of the ground is just completely covered in hair
and then there's the skeleton and you're looking at this and you're like,
oh,
match and what that must have been like to see.
Imagine being there while you see that fucking that wolf picking off every piece
of flesh and meat.
Yeah,
the first one that comes along.
Yeah.
Look at it that way.
That's what it looks like on the ground.
Shit.
Yeah.
That's the meat of the animal all picked off the bread for some reason.
The hair just hanging out and is it just,
that's even more disturbing?
I didn't expect that for some reason.
I figured like they did something with the hair.
No,
they just leave it on the ground.
They eat a lot of the skin.
Like the skin's gone.
Like the actual out outer skin like this.
It's like they spit out the hair coughing it up.
Yeah.
It's like they spit out the hair in the video of the,
it's either a cheetah or something.
You've seen a porcupine.
Have you seen that one where he's taken down the porcupine?
How's he taken out?
It's,
it's,
I don't know if you can Google it.
It's probably on the show it on.
Don't know when.
Whenever we show we show nature documentaries
always get pulled off.
It's a great video cause he stocks it and it's almost like he's going to let it
pass and he waits in the porcupines doing his thing but its quills or you know,
it's out.
It's,
it's sprouted.
It's ready to go and it comes up behind it and just pause under it and gets in
there and it gets attacked and then it pulls a little needles out,
licks the wound,
there's a little blood dripping and then it waits again and porcupines starts
waddling away and he walks in there and get somebody to fucking jabs at him.
It's just trying to pull this fucking like,
and they do this dance six or seven times and each time cleans a little quills
out,
looks the blood weights,
goes back in and finally on the last one gets them and you just watch him
fucking,
once he gets under there and grabs him,
he just slams him and then fucking tears into him.
It's amazing.
Just holds them down,
just holds him,
bleeds them out.
It's like squeezing the last toothpaste out of the tube.
You just clamping them down.
You mentioned how hard has to be to the point where you're trying to kill one of
those things,
right?
Porcupine and eat it with your face,
Like that's how hungry you are.
You're going to go out of your way to slowly reach under this thing's ball sack
and gut it,
right?
No one gets going to bleed you out as well,
like now,
right?
The barrier to entry nature,
so ruthless the existence,
the day to day existence of just trying to kill things with your face to stay
alive.
You know,
and you know,
eating grass and always be looking around,
right?
Everywhere you go,
you're fucking,
what the fuck was that sound?
Always waiting for some giant dog thing,
whether it's a wolf or a bear or a big cat thing.
These fucking things come on,
eat you and your family and they just eat you just jack you and start eating you
alive.
That's your life.
Your life is like eating grass and looking left and right.
Right.
And being ready to fucking bolt at any second.
Fuck this right.
And hope you can run just a little bit faster than Tommy.
That's beautiful,
beautiful nature.
That's our beautiful nature.
We are.
Perception of nature is so distorted.
Our perception is,
wow,
look at the eagles soaring over the beautiful,
like that's a dinosaur.
He's looking to murder,
right.
He's going to swoop down and you're just lucky.
You're big enough that he can pick you up.
Because if you,
if you are smaller,
if you were like rabbits size,
he was fuck your world up.
That Eagle who'd come down and fucking kill you.
Yeah.
That's not a show of freedom.
He's not flapping his patriotism in your face.
He's looking for food.
You'd imagine if,
how crazy would this be if global warming made the earth warmer and because the
earth got warmer,
eagles got more food and eagles got so big,
they started praying on Americans.
Would that be the most ironic shit ever?
If,
if globally,
that's our my fine movie that's coming out next set up,
set up a path in motion that turned eagles into giant 20 foot human eating
predators.
And we had a war with the eagles and it was all because of global warming cause
they had access to all that frozen land up in Alaska and Canada 24 hours a day.
Cause that's where they live.
Those fuckers,
they live on the north.
The north becomes like palm springs,
you know,
but water,
you know like a jungle,
constant food.
We just have a swarm
of eagles coming down to Seattle.
Fucking people up.
We go to war with the eagles.
Eagles are the sites of dragons.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Then the polar bears were got to deal with them where you have to swim on down
here I am at change causes a change in animals kind of.
How do we know that climate change isn't going to cause I'll tell you how would
you know there's climate change is real.
Climate change is like Obamacare.
It's not illegal
though.
The earth is calling on in cycles.
I would,
you know how cold it is out there today,
ed saw most six g degrees,
global warming,
global warming.
Now it's hilarious.
Did it?
Stephen Colbert had a funny line about that.
You know,
it's like saying like saying there's no global warming because it was cold out.
Today is like saying there's no global hunger cause I just had lunch,
right?
There's six.
I can see six taco trucks out this window.
Clearly people aren't hungry.
Yeah.
I might have paraphrased it.
I think it was Kobe or I might have paraphrased that,
but it's pretty close to what it was.
I stumbled through it,
but yeah,
there's this climate change going on.
The only question is like how much of it is because of us and it's gotta be some
of it.
Scalably we're fucking dumping shit into the sky all the time.
Pretend that that's not doing anything.
That seems a little disingenuous.
I mean,
why are you pretending?
Well,
and this tree,
I'm job with the idea that that's the only way we can do things.
It's so stupid.
What?
Where's,
where's the solar powered factories?
Bitch?
Where's the solar power clean?
I her,
every time I read another fucking story about some city getting just clumps of
their hair falling out in the shower because they're fracking 12 miles away.
Every time I see a new report or a new study,
I go,
man,
how?
Where's the,
where's the solar tax breaks?
Let's just stop feeding that industry and go to the most infinite clean resource
we have.
Please speaking,
which I'm going to have that dude from,
um,
from,
uh,
the fracking movie.
Gaslight.
Yeah.
Gas.
Oh yeah.
I haven't seen Gasland too,
but I saw a gas line one and I was like,
whoa.
And he's going to come on soon.
He'll be on,
uh,
like to thank me.
He might,
it might actually be next week we're working on now.
I love that.
But yeah,
great movie.
And that one also is a controversial movie and uh,
there's a lot of people that think that a lot of the stuff that he said was,
was not exactly accurate.
And some people have said that some of it is bullshit and other people said,
no,
that's the fracking industry trying to discredit him,
sir.
So I will give people the opportunity to ask me questions before that.
Just be me if you have any questions about like,
uh,
the movie or fracking.
But they made fracking illegal in New York,
New York state.
They just signed a bill saying out of environmental concerns,
the governor decided to make a fracking illegal,
which take on it.
It's like I don't know how many spots they've ruined.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't,
I mean the idea of cheap oil and it sounds nice and great and everything,
but I'm so not into at in 2015 since it's almost there,
it all we've learned about the consequences of poisoning the environment to just
wantonly do that without working out the technology to its fullest extent first.
Cause they're already coming up with new ways of fracking now that are less
harmful to the environment.
Like there was just some new release the other day of some new discovery.
Well okay,
well why didn't we wait until you guys made that cut?
No,
cause you greedy cunts didn't mind if you polluted a well you didn't mind if you
fucked up a lake.
You didn't mind.
A few ruined an ecosystem of a few square miles.
Just a few square miles.
But that's not,
that's not yours.
That's the earth's like if you're doing something and you know it's going to
ruin a lake forever,
like don't do that.
That's fucking stupid.
Don't do that.
Another layer of that is,
you know,
when I was down during the BP spill and they were spraying,
which unprecedented amounts of corrects it all over the Gulf.
Yeah.
Hundreds of thousands of gallons of,
of a chemical which uh,
had a proprietary materials list and I'm like,
look,
if you're spraying thousand hundreds of thousands of gallons of something into a
water supply,
that is a shared resource.
You don't get to keep the sauce secret.
This isn't the colonel Sanders recipe here.
Same thing,
same thing with fucking fracking.
It's like we don't know specifically what chemical cocktail is going on.
We can get traces of it,
but we have no idea what's being pumped into this shared resource and it's not
yours.
Right.
And even if we do know,
if you do know what those chemicals are,
do we know the longterm consequences of introducing those chemicals to the
environment now and what are we willing to accept those longterm consequences?
Maybe you are,
maybe he isn't.
If you guys,
you know,
we have to be able to figure out what's correct and incorrect and how much is
based on like exaggeration and how much is based on fear and paranoia versus
propaganda.
Like where the fuck is the scientists so we know where are they and then you've
got to look at the scientist.
Where are you?
Get your money.
Have you ever gotten any money from a fracking company you get,
you get paid for the oil company.
You ever done any consulting?
Yeah.
That cause that's what happened with the financial crisis.
You ever see the inside job?
Do you ever see that?
Oh Yeah Woo.
That's a fucking great one,
right?
You find out that these guys who enact policy then they,
they then go and get jobs at the company where these professors of economics,
they propose like certain standards based on their knowledge because their
economic professors and then they get these fucking juicy jobs when they retire,
when they stopped teaching and they make better.
It's like doctors getting bonuses for prescribing certain prescription pills.
I made my quota.
Great.
Now I'm going to bail out and go work for one of those companies as a
consultant.
Tip Paper,
Kevin,
bright red.
It's a race,
Joe Rogan.
I'm trying to be in front,
just trying to get paid kid trying to get dead paper.
I've got to do what I gotta do.
If you want me to propose some Shanky as laws,
let's do this and that's what's going on.
I mean,
that's that if people have done that and have profited than it has been shown
that the deregulation of the markets and all that was disadvantage or was bad
for the economy.
And if that is the case,
you know,
like,
Whoa,
how did that happen?
Oh,
you guys did it.
and you guys got money from that.
You've got to get that money.
Yeah,
you stole
that money.
Good luck with that one,
Steven.
Little fucking weasel.
What do you see today?
That shit policy creating fuck face.
It's a fucked up policy that,
you know,
the torture memos stuff today.
The New York Times,
did you say is your more towards what they're calling the New York Times?
Uh,
which if you believe that any traditional publication is still going to have
maybe an ounce of impact on a broad level,
a lot of people point to that.
Um,
they are calling for basically for,
uh,
for the Justice Department to look at prosecuting Cheney Bush in name checking
all of the entire,
the CIA,
the psychologist who came up with the torture stuff.
You know,
it's like the ones who created the program there.
They're actively calling for investigations and potentially prosecution.
Dan,
it's about damn time wow.
The rectal feeding things like what?
And like someone was trying to justify it.
Well that's all we were going to do.
Nutrients and to patients who don't want to eat.
And I don't think it works like that.
I don't think you shove food up dudes,
assholes.
They still alive.
Like what is reverse flog raw.
But what did this whole,
they've got to plunge the oats.
Like is that who we are?
We're,
we're stuffing food up people's assholes.
Is that we are who we are when it comes to like the lowest dungeon of secrecy in
American policy when it comes to maybe not the lowest by the way,
just one load that we know about.
Yeah.
One one that we found out about it.
What am I some darker shit they've done.
But you know what man?
Well there was a real,
there was a photo on my Facebook while they had the head was an image of a dude
and mid descent jumping out of one of the towers from nine 11 and the,
the main text on the top was like,
uh,
you think water,
you think I'm spraying water in someone's face is torture.
Just remember what they did to us.
You know,
it's like,
like if you believe in,
you know,
Eagle screams and seeing that go out there like I had,
it lured me in,
I had to like debate this with people who would like and share that and distill
the argument down to that.
And again,
it's just like there's no denying that wrong has been done to this country.
And there's no denying that there are people out there that wake up in their
first thought out of bed is how can I fuck up America that absolutely exists?
That's real.
Okay.
Um,
but how do you think you create more people like that?
You know,
what,
what process leads to people having that sort of mentality.
And now there's a certain percentage of people that would say,
even if we gave a fair trial and found someone guilty and executed them for
planning for crimes,
that they would still have family members back home who are super fucking pissed
that his bed is true.
That there's nothing that you can do to change their minds.
But when a drone blows up a building and there's 15 innocence killed with that,
well that's mothers and fathers,
that's neighbors,
that's cousins.
There's an ancillary fallout.
Where are you?
We're just breeding that mentality.
You're sowing the seeds of descent,
you know,
your,
your riling people up.
And when a torture memo like this comes out and we hear about our,
our,
our moral high ground is completely taken out.
It was taken out at the knees.
There's very damning report.
If you believe a percentage of what goes on in there,
you know,
you want to stop this cycle.
That's not the way to do it.
It's not the way to get credible information that's been proven and it's only a
way to create,
yeah.
More hatred and the,
I mean,
they did stuff that was just unimaginable.
Like they froze to death.
Yeah,
we'll put them there,
but they're me on a cold floor,
naked handcuffed to a wall froze to death.
I mean,
people in coffins couldn't breathe.
He died dead.
Couldn't,
he couldn't maintain his body temperature.
He died.
That's just fucking crazy.
It's fucking crazy.
I get mean if you want someone dead killed them.
Okay,
but don't do that.
Right?
Like what are you doing?
You're,
you're freezing them to death.
Just if someone is a murderer or someone's done horrible things in these,
you know,
it's been deemed that he's guilty.
Just execute them.
Don't fucking do this.
And if you're doing this just to get information there has gotta be a better
way.
Did you try ecstasy?
Right?
Did you give him ecstasy first?
You know what?
Kindness.
A lot of shit.
I bet you get that guy next up.
Oh,
you can't do that.
It's illegal.
Okay,
but what did people,
the freezes Dick,
what if you put it in a magic bullet and shove it up his butt?
Then it's totally illegal into what you feed him.
MTMA roles.
Fucking a man.
You know some people I was getting into this discussion and they were like,
well,
do you know how expensive it is to have a trial?
Why should we waste money on a terrorist trial and go,
do you know how fucking expensive to run black site operations with these CIA
salaries where these dudes that whose chests are filled with medallions and
striped bars are putting tubes and dude's ass holes and paddling.
I'm naked down hallways as they put chains around their neck.
Like that's expensive too.
Yeah.
I would say this is not the way to handle anything.
This is not the way to do it.
Rectal feeding.
Should never be on your menu.
That's not noble.
Capitalis chilies.
Captain America would never directly feed somebody.
Think about that way when it comes to what we should and shouldn't do and
dealing with bad guys.
Think about what the fuck captain America would do.
Okay.
He would never stuff a tube up someone's ass and force feed them a hamburger.
He wouldn't do that.
So you shouldn't do that.
If you're going to work for the CIA,
you should at least uphold the standards of Captain America.
Actually Joe and uh,
issue 17,
Captain America,
he did give a rectal feeding to doctor Gizmo.
He slipped the tube up his robe.
Well,
he rectally fed him the truth.
Put this meal on my shield and just jam it in their freedom.
Right up your ass.
This is the cock of Free Da da Da.
Yeah.
He actually flew to the courthouse with that dude in the doggy style position.
Stick in that car,
answers holding onto the back of his hair as he was flying through the air,
watching an ad for Coca Cola.
Captain America couldn't even fly.
You know,
he was just like the first guy on EPO.
Can you jump on a shield and fly?
Is that not a thing?
No.
We thought it could throw a shield and leap on it and kind of surf the wave.
I'll kind of jump harder than you are higher than you or I,
but he was in no way a superhero.
I mean it wasn't even like a bird like bird to be like,
bitch can't even get off the ground.
He'd be like,
oh,
high jump.
I'm kept in America.
I'm on not super soldier serum.
He was the first steroid user.
That's exactly what it was like.
The United States up with awesome steroids that make you with pride and joy of
America don't turn turn.
Why would they just give that to everybody and have all America filled with
captain America's?
Why rely on this one dude?
You fucking idiots.
You made some shit that obviously keeps this guy alive since the 1930s he looks
fantastic.
Give it up,
bitch.
Start passing out the super soldier CRM.
Why don't you mass producing that?
Why isn't it for say like cigarettes?
How come the super soldier serums and everywhere.
Oh,
you like having us week relying on Captain America.
You fucking shit bags.
Give Up.
Give up the seeker soldiers serum.
If we all had secret soldiers serum,
we wouldn't have to worry about isis or al Qaeda.
We'd all be jacked and we'd have shields and we'd be jumping over buildings and
we'd have America filled with bad mother fuckers instead of ironic fedora
wearing douche bags with,
with bird like bone structures.
No,
there'd be so much roid rage.
It'd be awful.
It'd be an American [inaudible] on the DMV.
If everybody was captain America though,
you guys are so wrong.
All you have to do is just inject morals and ethics into him the same time you
inject them along with super soldiers here who gets to define the moral code,
super kindness vote.
A villain is going to put a back door in that the guardians a piece,
they're going to put a moral backdoor in it so they can activate all the super
soldiers.
He's in the Guardian or isn't the watchman the greatest cartoon or slash comic
books slash adventure movie ever because it was so like kind of morally
ambiguous.
Sure.
They were all like,
everyone's kind of bad and some sort of a weird way.
Like even the good guys,
we're fucked up.
Everybody's got flaws.
Yeah.
Like in a major way,
in a way that like,
you know,
we've seen like Tony Stark likes to drink the team and in the bottle.
I remember that episode of Iron Man.
I was a little kid.
I was a big iron man fan and I was reading color comic book and the episode was
called a demon in the bottle and Tony Stark iron man was having a hard time with
the whiskey,
the alcohol.
He just couldn't stop drinking.
They can find Tara in Netsuite,
but he can't find his own Daymond.
His bottle demon in the bottle was getting a total star.
Amazing.
I mean that was like the word.
He wasn't raping anybody or killing and murdering people to watch men murder
people.
You know,
they'll,
they'll kill people,
stomp heads,
you know,
like some of the shit that they do is like really dark man.
What he's showing is that it?
Yeah,
he's looking in the mirror.
He can't even believe himself.
He looks like the punisher
iron face.
He's sweating with his suit on underneath his clothes.
They're always,
always,
always had like a little bit of a torn shirt.
There's something
that's off afraid would happen to me.
She was stumbling down a flight of stairs when I was a kid.
Man.
Comic books were so vacation is his hair dyed cosplay blue.
Did you see that?
Oh that was always the case.
It's like superman always had blue hair.
Yeah.
I think it was like a highlight thing.
Like that's how they decided to go with highlights because it's hard to make
like a black black hair with like white highlights.
Right?
Right.
It's like what is the shiny part
look like?
So they decided to go with blue.
Like almost universally.
It's really like,
occasionally we'll have like brown,
like like Brown in between the black,
but a lot of times it's blue and you don't even question it.
Like,
yeah,
they're just punk rocker.
You got some weird weird fucking blew their iron man goes to hot topic and gets
punky colors.
Yeah.
Like we just accept it.
Yeah,
he's got blue hair,
but he's cool as fuck.
Look,
it's blue hair man.
I love it.
Oh look at him.
He's so depressed in his chair.
Bumped doesn't look uncomfortable.
He's wearing a big metal like take off your pants.
Yeah,
I guess unless you just now he must,
he must encounter skins or something,
right?
Like,
I mean you would say for the first week you're iron man and then you just
develop a tolerance.
We never explained how it looks like metal,
but Ben's like your muscles as it was that ever explained.
Like how does that work?
Because it doesn't have like real joints to be made of unobtainium or something.
There's some rule we don't know about.
How goofy is that word on a Panini?
Tanium wasn't that,
isn't there.
And it was movie was Avatar.
Was it advertised?
Yeah.
Get funding.
I remember Adam [inaudible] was being,
you know,
get his clot unobtainium like
that seems like really uncreative.
I haven't possessing them.
You can't have it.
I'm looking forward to those new movies more than anything.
James Camera.
It's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
there was,
I loved those movies writes.
It's an article just yesterday,
I think it was,
it came out that said Avatar gross 9.2 billion.
Dot.
Whatever the fucking number was like 92 million or what?
900 million worldwide.
But it didn't leave a cultural impact.
Who said that?
A,
it's been swimming around like mad.
This article of like it didn't leave a lasting impact.
What's where people agreeing with that?
Yeah.
They were saying like,
oh,
you're right.
Avatar was kind of a failure.
I mean it made a lot of money,
but it didn't lead to any real in depth discussions about why,
because the hottest girl ever that broke up with you and you were depressed to
the point where you don't bring her up anymore.
That's why two people got avatar depression.
Do you remember that shit?
People were getting avatar depression.
Don't tell me it didn't make a cultural impact of fucking idiot.
Whoever wrote that.
It's ridiculous.
That movie was spectacular.
It was PSI Phi at its best dances with wolves.
Yes,
exactly.
It was Pocahontas too.
It was the same movie.
Who Cares?
Right?
They're all awesome.
It was awesome.
Avatar was the shit.
If you didn't enjoy that movie,
just as a movie,
you're a jaded fuck cause you see it in three d in theaters.
It's like people go,
well I don't like three d.
It's not good.
I'm like,
you can't judge Avatar by the upconverted bullshit you see at the local hardwood
chair.
Fucking multip.
You gotta go gotta go Imax Three d?
Yes.
Oh,
I wouldn't have loved that movie in nearly as much as if it were in imax three d
I gotta be honest.
I loved it,
but I needed that.
I needed some fucking sativa and Imax and it's 12.1 sound system and fucking
Avatar titties.
Right.
Depth in my eyeballs.
That was amazing.
Here's what people don't,
oh,
I can't tell you what you do
and don't get,
but this is what I don't get about people's reaction to it.
The same people would probably be comic book fans.
You know,
there's a lot of people that are like snobs over a movie like that,
but may actually be into like other genres while there except plot holes like
that.
Of course.
But what Avatar is,
is a comic book movie.
It's a comic book movie.
It's,
it's almost cartoonish in the fact that,
you know,
everything's going to work out in the end.
You know,
you know the good guys are going to get through and the basket that beat
Goliath,
you got a bad marine.
He's in his fucking bad outfit.
Like you're going to kick that guy's ass.
The whole thing is like,
but it's a visual masterpiece.
I mean it's,
you're watching this world play out this like,
it's a little homogenized.
It's a little pasteurize and it's a little mainstream.
Guilty as charged.
It certainly is.
But so what,
just enjoy it.
It's amazing trees with the fiber optics and the dragons and grade fucking,
oh my God,
it's incredible to hair doc dude.
It's incredible.
You mentioned that like the the,
these guys love comic books and get their picking this apart because there's
subsets of nerds who will go out of their way to excuse or explain logic flaws
and star wars or star Trek,
anything star related.
They were Lord of the rings.
They will cook up formulas that explain the science behind a wizard staff.
They will do everything they can to defend a franchise they love,
but if they will apply that exact same violent hatred,
white hatred to a new property that no,
there's unobtainium stupid and then they will just tear it down with that same
laser focus.
But I'd loved about Avatar was that a bunch of,
not just,
I loved watching it.
It was fun.
I thought it was just a fun movie,
but what I loved is watching all these people with this quote unquote avatar
depression talking about it.
There was all these people that were saying like,
that movie made me realize how unrewarding my regular everyday life is and how
unspiritual unconnected I am too,
to the energy of the universe and life and like those,
those,
those beings,
those Navi,
they weren't free.
You know,
they lived like flying,
you know,
nomads and shooting bows and arrows and shit.
And for whatever reason,
it's just like so much more appealing than the shitbag life you have getting
stuck in traffic driving to your cubicle,
right where you constantly feel out of balance and out of peace with your
environment to most men live lives of silent desperation.
That was,
was it Ralph Waldo Emerson?
Who the fuck said that thorough?
I think Thoreau said that.
It's one of my favorite all time quotes.
Most men live lives of silent desperation,
you know,
and you see that avatar movie.
God,
I want to fly a fucking dragon.
I just want to live in a hammock and a tree.
Just live off the land and justly avoid all the monsters and shoot them down as
I leap over them.
And just cliff,
if
you're alive and exciting times instead of this fucking traffic and sneezing and
Bullshit and Oh,
I got laid off,
great.
I think I'll shoot myself.
You know,
I mean this is the world that people are trapped in,
in a,
in a lot of ways.
And so to say that that movie was culturally significant or it didn't have a
cultural impact,
it might not have for you are okay because first of all,
it shouldn't have,
it should have just been an enjoyable film,
which I thought it was,
but you can't deny all this.
They came up with a term for how people reacted,
like the withdrawal that they had from that movie.
I mean,
that's how fucking powerful impact,
just because it didn't get you just because you're a little fucking movie snob
fedora wearing movies knob.
Cause I said,
you know what I saw,
I saw a Fox catcher,
um,
I've heard about that is it's a lot of ways,
a very good movie and a lot of ways,
a very good movie.
Spoiler alert.
Steve Carell knocks it out of the fucking park.
Um,
what is his name?
The a beautiful,
handsome man.
I of course,
you know his name.
What's his name?
Channing Tatum.
You know,
all the celebrity gossip.
They fuck Channing Tatum.
He knocks it out of the park.
Mark refollow wears Nike,
Mark Rufallo who plays,
uh,
the hulk in the Avengers movie.
He plays the brother David Schultz,
and it's all based on a true story,
a story that I'm a very aware of because mark Schultes actually fought in the
UFC.
Now here's the,
I mean the movie's a very good in some ways,
but here's the issue that I had with it.
Spoiler alert,
stop.
Now if you don't want to go further,
I want to say they fucked with the timeline in the 1980s,
they showed the UFC on TV in 1988 or they show them watching the UFC,
talking about it like the UFC wasn't even invented until 1993.
So why would you make a true story about real people in a really fucked up
actual real life murder that it's incredibly creepy movie and a lot of ways it's
really well done.
But,
and then lie about the timeline by five years.
Other than being an acronystic,
does it play as a central point in the plot?
Yes.
Okay.
Because at the end of it,
he winds up being a mixed martial arts fighter,
which is true.
But what's not true is in the movie they put him in against some random Russian
guy.
I think they'd like a white guy.
He didn't fight a white guy.
I fought a black guy,
fought a guy named big dairy daddy Goodrich and big daddy.
Good.
Richard is the only MMA fight that Mark Schultz ever had.
So to have the end of the movie having him about the fight,
a white guy like you guys just invented some shit.
Like why did you go with a white guy?
And then when they're watching the fight in 1988 which was actually taking place
in 1993 it was big daddy,
good rich fighting.
Paul Herrera.
So like,
I don't know what the fuck they were doing when they were doing that.
Like that is not just unnecessary but jarring and insulting in a way to anybody
that's in mixed martial arts fan.
Because if you're like me and do like a historian mixed martial arts
and you watched that,
you go,
why are you doing that?
Like you're dealing with a real Olympic gold medalists who was really involved
in a real life scenario.
We had a real live,
crazy super rich guy.
Shoot his brother.
Like all those things are real.
It's a nutty story.
W W when you add in a bunch of shit that I know is not real,
it makes me question all the other,
everything else,
and I don't want to have to do research on this guy's entire life and find out
how much of what you put in there.
It was just total bullshit.
But when they do that,
man,
when they just fuck with reality and put unnecessarily,
they changed the timeline of these guys watching the UFC by five fucking years.
That's so irresponsible.
It's just dumb.
It was a big part of this guy's life.
Mark Schultz would have been the fucking UFC heavyweight champion of the world.
He was a phenomenal wrestler.
He was one of a handful of Olympic gold medalist who fought in MMA,
but he only fought once and dominated this guy who was a really tough guy and
everybody was wondering what could have happened with him that he went on to
coach.
He was coaching at Brigham Young University and they wouldn't let them fight in
MMA.
They said,
if you fought in the UFC,
we're gonna know your contract.
There was no money in the UFC back then.
So he backed away.
He could have been heavyweight champion the world.
I mean he was just a fucking animal stud wrestler.
Ridiculously strong.
And so when you watch stuff like that in this movie about this guy's life,
it makes me question the whole movie.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
Like why are you changing reality?
Why you?
Why you putting in some stuff like that?
Like he fought a white guy,
he didn't fight.
He fought one guy ever.
His whole fucking life.
It's already had a hundred MMA fights.
You're creating a fictional opponent to move on.
Is that like the line along the intern that was doing the research for that
scene in the script,
you know,
had to cull through 500 matches and pick one to represent his career.
Yeah.
And there was one,
it wasn't even in the UFC in the movie.
Like the movie didn't show the UFC,
it didn't show the octagon and didn't,
I mean it was like a cage but it wasn't the UFC.
It was like generic fight promotion.
It was a UFC though in real life.
Yeah.
That and it was weird cause they didn't even pick like an old,
the oldest one,
they picked one from 1994 so it wasn't even 1993 UFC.
It was at night.
The one that he was watching TV.
Yeah.
When he fought Paul Herrera,
when the big daddy Goodrich far Paul Herrera.
It's so stupid.
So they fucked with the timeline for no reason.
It's interesting cause like that's a piece of knowledge that the average viewer
is not going to have most likely.
But it makes you wonder why they come.
I'm sure they compressed it for time,
right?
They wanted to plant the seed of why he's going to watch this thing and become
this thing and okay.
But to your point,
it does a huge disservice if it makes you question the legitimacy,
legitimacy or the accuracy of everything else in the film.
In
my opinion,
there was no reason for them to put it in the UFC at all.
Like there's no reason for them to show that part of his life.
And it was only one fight that he had.
What was really crazy,
it was the fact this guy was an Olympic gold medalist who,
you know,
it shows you how difficult it is for these guys to make money rather training
and how difficult it is to come up with sponsorship.
So when this really rich guy,
John Dupont came along and wanting to fund the Olympic team and Olympic
wrestling team,
they had a deal with this insane,
crazy guy that was like pretending to be a wrestler that was sort of financing
this.
Steve Carell knocks it out of the park,
man.
I heard people don't even realize it's him.
They watched the movie and they leave.
Not even realizing he's so
fucking creepy,
man.
He's so creepy.
Do you see bird man?
Um,
no,
I did not see Birdman.
Yeah,
put that on the,
put that on the instant instant watch mark in the UFC for months after Dave was
murdered.
Holy Shit.
That's incredible.
He finally UFC four months after his brother was murdered.
That's justice.
Unbelievable.
Wow.
And that was that.
That all happened in 1996.
Wow.
Fuck.
But I just don't understand why they make a movie about a real live situation
that is insanely compelling and add some shit and fuck with timelines and I
think maybe UFC got paid are paid them to do.
That doesn't make any sense.
That doesn't make any sense because they didn't have the UFC at the end.
It wasn't,
UFC didn't show the arc.
I mean I think it was even round if I might be wrong about that.
But I remember looking at it like that's the wrong sized cage.
I remember looking at the scenario like this is not,
is not like what it looked like when Mark Schultz stepped in the octagon.
He,
he fought in the UFC just before I started working there.
I think he fought like,
oh I want to say UFC nine,
I think it is.
And I came along and UFC 12,
so it was just right before I got there.
They weren't,
you know,
the way they had this setup,
it was,
it was incorrect.
It was smaller than it really is.
There's a lot of things were weird about it,
but the weirdest things that he was fighting a white guy.
But if I one guy ever,
so at the end of the movie,
why making a white guy like what the fuck are you doing?
And not only that,
they also didn't account for the fact that you're talking about like a six year
time gap between them watching it in 1988 the murder and him,
uh,
getting,
starting fighting in the UFC,
like you just created this time dilemma that doesn't make any sense.
Like how did Mark Schultz age six years like that?
All of a sudden he's in the UFC cause you can't deny when his debut is,
you're going to deny the timeline of his actual fight.
Well that fight was in 1996.
This whole thing doesn't make any sense.
This is stupid.
Well that's what does it inherently change the story?
Oh
it stinks of producer Greece,
right?
You know that someone,
some executive type character wanting to get their greasy pause on,
let's have them sitting around watching the UFC or some screenwriter that
doesn't respect the history of the sport.
Like you do imagine that they did that about baseball.
If they made a movie that was a Babe Ruth,
but the timeline was five years off to when Babe Ruth was actually playing
baseball.
People would go fucking crazy.
They did
yo fuck get red dodge rose Denton thought play Doh.
Five got fucking piece of shit movie.
You don't fucking know shit about baseball for a bunch of Chuck Riding Hollywood
got soccer that are fucking
with the American pastime.
But if you have it about the UFC,
like nobody gives a shit.
Like,
so,
uh,
it's five years off with six years off,
whatever it is.
It's off.
You're off.
You don't have to,
it doesn't have to be off,
but should I say the movie?
It's a good move.
Alright.
Fuck yeah,
it's a good movie.
Channing Tatum knocks out of the park.
He looks like a real wrestler too.
Like when he moves,
he moves good.
Like the wrestling scenes are not offensive at all.
They're good.
You know,
I mean there's certain like you watch like certain martial arts scenes in movies
and you're like,
get the fuck out of here.
Like this is so weak.
The kicks look fake.
You can tell they're not really hitting each other then not really punching each
other full blast.
It's just hard to fake.
But they must've done a lot of really hard wrestling training because he moves
real good.
Like he hits,
he hits takedowns and positions.
He hits a very smooth.
So either he wrestled at one point in his career and his life rather,
and he's like John from that Bri relearning those skills or he learned them for
the movie.
But either way,
it's totally possible.
It's never going to look 100% legit because it's a planned outcome.
It's like it's planned that this guy's going to take this guy down.
So it always has this sort of stink about it.
And whenever there's any sort of choreographed motions going on in a move,
we could do a movie about pride,
but not about UFC then.
Well,
even looser trying to was choreographed.
Yeah.
I'm sure there's been some choreographed fights in the UFC in the early days.
There were some,
there were some fights.
Yeah.
There was a Vito Belfort fight that a lot of people thought was at work.
Oh,
actually that was a,
that was actually pride.
He fought the ghetto man,
Joe Charles,
and got him at a really quick arm bar and a lot of people were shocked because
they knew that Joe Charles train with v Tour,
you know?
And a lot of people are like,
hmm,
I mean maybe v toward decided not to punch him.
You,
maybe they made a sort of an agreement because like back then Vito was the
motherfucker,
you know,
he was,
he was really good and unusually good with his standup.
I mean,
he's still really good.
He's challenging for the title next month or in February rather than,
so he's already,
I mean,
he's at the top of the food chain right now,
but back then,
see,
right now there's a lot of good strikers as a lot of guys who have a lot of good
hand techniques and you know,
good stand up guys.
But back then there was only a handful of them and Vito was at the top of that
heap.
Like when [inaudible] came around,
he was 19 nobody had ever seen anybody with hand speed like his,
when he fought Treg telling me that was his first fight in the UFC.
He stepped forward and everybody knew he's a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt,
but he just unloads with these punches.
Like they made me wait,
wait,
beautiful fucking lightening fast punches.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck?
But he fought Joe.
Charles just won't take them down.
Armbar,
you know,
and everybody's like,
hmm.
And you think because they trained together there was like,
hey man,
don't bust up my face too much if you're going to beat me,
do it.
Or,
or it could be that Joe Charles knew what the fuck was going to go down and say,
listen,
I know I can't be you,
so let's just,
you know,
even this arm,
this is my good arm.
Bend it too much.
We'll tap you don't me brother.
I will.
And that's the thing,
like a guy like [inaudible] tour is so nice.
Like a lot of people think that that's how he lost to John Jones.
He caught John Jones up perfect arm bar and he popped his elbow like a bunch of
times,
but John never tapped and veto even said that he relaxed his grip on it because
he felt bad that he was breaking this guy's arm.
Right.
You know,
like I'm in a sense that he was taken aback and he said that he should've held
onto it.
I believe that's what he said.
I'm sorry.
I apologize if I was incorrect,
but I was pretty sure.
And one of the interviews,
he's a very nice guy,
but you know,
with striking,
you either hit a guy,
you don't,
you know,
it's not a matter of holding a technique and he,
he,
he bugging eds people.
That's going to be a really interesting fight.
Who was he fighting?
He's fighting Chris Weidman for the middle weight title.
But the point is,
anyway,
back to Fox catcher.
Really good movie.
Really good movie that I'm Channing Tatum.
Guy Kills it even looks like mark shoulds.
Like he did something with his jaw or judges jaw forward while he's talking all
the time.
So he actually looks like the guy in a lot of ways,
you know,
he looks different than it usually looks.
And his wrestling was super respectable and Mark Ruffalo was awesome.
They both walked like wrestlers.
They,
they did.
Uh,
they really did a really good job and it's fine because like,
especially like Channing Tatum,
he does a lot of funny movies,
you know,
don't do a lot of silly movies.
So it's weird to see him play this like super intense,
you know,
uh,
really dark kind of character in this movie.
And fucking Tarell's.
Amazing man.
You don't even believe it's him.
That's what I,
every review that I've read is like,
oh,
I had to wait for the credits to find out who that amazing actor was.
Sneak up on them,
changed his face and gave him this weird nose.
It's fucking good,
dude.
You were catching it.
You really buy it.
He's so good.
You really buy that.
He's just crazy.
Someone was saying I'm Ashton Kutcher is doing,
I know that sounds like a setup to a joke,
but it's,
yeah,
he's doing Jujitsu and that he's done in the past and he's playing a role in
some movie where whoever is training him says he's fucking phenomenal and he's
really committed and you're just going to blow you away with this
transformation.
Well,
he's a purple belt.
You know,
he's a purple belt in there.
Higa Machado.
Who is,
uh,
my,
in Jujitsu we use the term master,
don't get crazy.
My master a Jacques Machado.
That's the top of the heap.
I have a black belt under John Jacques Machado and John John,
which try to give Eddie Bravo is black pearl and have a black pilling Eddie too.
So the ultimate top guy,
the food chain in our lineage is John Jacques Machado.
His brother Hagen is also a bad motherfucker and he can Machado,
um,
gave Ashton Kutcher a purple belt if he can.
Me Trial gives you a purple belt.
You're a fucking purple belt.
No,
he's not handing those out because if you're
be score,
it doesn't mean shit.
You gotta Roll and you've got to roll with people.
You can't,
they don't just give you that.
You have to spar.
That's the only,
I mean there's martial arts where you don't spar on your way to getting belts,
like [inaudible] stuff,
right.
For like little kids and stuff.
But in Jujitsu you have to spar.
You just have to,
you know,
you,
there's no other way around it and yeah,
you kind of go full blast.
And would they just evaluate your technique and situations and go,
okay,
yeah,
you did the right thing there.
So clearly you have a level of knowledge that has this color.
The guy like Egan,
he can watch your role in five minutes.
He could probably figure out what you are.
You know you might be a super athletic purple belt but you make some mistakes
and you might a a brown belt who's been around for a long time but doesn't have
the athleticism,
try tap black belts but you have a lot of knowledge.
He could tell like right away,
like if someone does like certain like set someone up,
they try to do something and then the counter they hit him with the counter and
then they tap a guy.
You're like,
oh that's some slick shit.
And then you get to see like how many times can that guy do that?
Like is it just you get lucky this one time and it's a matter of consistency of
movement.
But it's like chess.
If you could add pieces,
you know like everybody says it's like human chess sort of,
but you might only have like a couple of pieces.
You might have like a footlocker and a guillotine.
Some guys only have one move.
And they do it over and over and over and over and over again.
They're just so good at it.
You can't stop that one move.
That's a strategy that some guys employ and there's a lot of guys that are like
that are that are essentially black belts.
It's weird and they have all those other techniques but this one they rely on
all the time or you're a guy like Eddie Bravo type character that has a hundred
things you could tap you with at any given moment.
It was just kind of practicing on,
you just wished Durbin when someone's rolling with somebody else and they know
that like a potential belt evaluation or is it like a test is on the line,
right?
I'm telling him to roll or is it just completely depends on the instructor.
Different instructors do it different ways.
Some instructors want to see you compete like in a test situation or they want
to put you in front of the class and show,
put a lot of pressure on you and see how you react and some want to see you at
your very best in a casual,
relaxed environment.
Where you're not nervous and they want to see what it was,
your actual skill level and then see if you maintain that skill level when you
get tested,
got,
you know,
when you do.
So it's completely depends on the,
um,
the,
uh,
the style of teaching of the instructor.
But instructors almost always we'll put you in a situation where there's like,
maybe it will have four people roll and the other people stay.
Like,
one of the things they'll do is they'll do drills where like,
you're on the ground,
like you have to go on your back and a guy,
a new fresh guy gets on top of you for seven minutes and tries to tap.
You don't keep your keeping your massage.
Um,
and then if you tap that guy,
you get to stay.
If he taps you,
you have to go.
Or if you guys stalemate,
you both get out.
Sometimes there's drills like that.
So when he does something like that,
he's evaluating how you perform under pressure,
uh,
how you performed with a bunch of people.
So my point being,
if Ashton Kutcher got a purple belt from Hagen Machado,
that Shit's legit.
There's no,
no one gets fake purple belts.
What does purple belt mean?
It means you a blue belt is dangerous.
A guy who's got a blue belt con fuck the average person out.
If they,
if they get in a situation where it turns into a grappling match,
they're going to know things.
The average person doesn't know.
Purple Belt is a level where you should be able to tap blue belts fairly
consistent.
Really?
Yeah.
So that's,
that's another level removed.
And purple belts can oftentimes tap brown belts.
I've seen purple belts get lucky and type flapper.
Black belts if they have like one specific mood they're really good at is very
possible.
So purple belt is dangerous.
That's my point.
They might not have all the knowledge,
but they're dangerous enough.
So if Ashton Kutcher's a purple belt,
that's all.
It's God damn impressed.
I love that.
I love hearing handsome bastard.
It's got everything going for him.
Where is he on your list?
The above.
Goslings above
his head to the left.
Upper left.
Channing Tatum is above in the tax and the ceilings just holding those posters
there.
Jay Z and Beyonce are together holding hands on his wall and one side is it
likes to lie Miley Cyrus the poster cause you're good so hard.
It just collects Miley Cyrus is pointing to his toothpaste jar for that on his
wall.
You're saying North Korea is suffering a complete internet outage?
Yeah.
All four of the big pipe pipes are all four computers for computer.
You think they did you think they just sent some fucking either anonymous or
down or shot some holes and come pipes?
Come on.
I think anonymous is fucking with them for sure.
But I mean that's how much is the government,
the hiding under anonymous.
There's no way to to know who's launching what.
Beautiful.
Just keep the hose.
Can they,
can they do that?
Do you think they have a cutoff switch somewhere where they could just hit the
switch?
Like the government though?
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
if you can take just simple packet flooding when you have enough bandwidth where
you call up Papa,
Comcast,
and Verizon,
these backbone operators and be like,
Hey,
do me a favor.
Let's redirect like 12 terabytes of bullshit to their front door right now and
that is just ringing until sparks are flying out in the computers.
Just can't crunch that information.
They can do that all day long.
Crazy.
That's a strategy that you can do with cars.
That's brute force.
It's the same.
Crazy.
You can see me what I'm in in their goofy fucking system.
If you could do that,
you can do that.
Wait a minute.
You could just send packets and just killed their security that with anybody you
could just,
you could get better.
I mean in any medium you could get 50 people to surround a human being and just
screaming at them.
That's it.
They just use the Metallica to torture dudes in the CIA.
Black sites,
they were just blasting it at 75 decibels,
but for a week it should go fucking cuckoo.
Go loopy.
There was a guy who
who's doing this,
um,
this speech and he was,
uh,
he was labeled a men's right advocate.
So all these feminists got outside of the university hall where was,
I think it was University of Toronto.
I'm not sure.
I think it was that.
And they screamed and yelled in the hall and then set off the fire alarms.
Yeah.
So that this guy could not,
couldn't give a speech and his speech,
yeah.
It turns out the guy wasn't even a men's rights advocate.
The whole thing was like completely blown out.
Like the thing they had like completely misappropriated or misquoted him on
things.
People just made up quotes,
made up his positions and then everybody got behind it and got super aggressive
with it.
But it's like,
it's kind of hilarious that that is the exact strategy they all went around went
just,
you can't talk about that.
You're not allowed to.
I don't know what you're going to say,
but whatever you're going to say,
I don't think you should be allowed to say it can't even,
it's the backseats Aerostar van tactic where two brothers are fighting and the
other just screams at one.
It's,
I don't care what you're saying,
you're not being heard.
You could step in and stop someone from ta,
I mean you would have to demonstrate that they were like a hate group or
committing a crime and you can't with this guy like so like they just decided
that this was what they going to do and that's
fascism.
Like that's,
that's like that's really dangerous.
You're not,
that's,
everybody had been a vote Joe.
You know,
it's not kindness.
Nah,
I mean it's like those people's buddied with their voice.
You're interfering with those people's ability to listen to someone communicate
because you don't even,
you don't even know what he's about to say.
You have no knowledge of it whatsoever.
Appearing with free speech from the perspective of those that are there going,
wow,
that's their free speech.
No,
they're deciding that they want to do that.
Their vote,
they get to vote with their voice.
That's what they're thinking.
Absolutely.
But wait a minute,
then people can just shout you down all day.
You don't have to think that that should be an issue.
Nope.
It clearly it is.
I mean there's rules against that.
In certain areas you can be disorderly and removed.
For City University,
it's ridiculous.
It's the you're terrorist threats because a woman is giving a speech on feminism
and video games or sexism in video games,
that's just as bad.
You just didn't have the balls to show up and scream at her.
You called in and anonymous threat.
Any calling in if any anonymous threat.
It's fucking gross on whatever side.
I mean we could just say that anybody willing to do that is is a piece of shit.
These are bad people.
Anybody who's doing that,
whether it's weird real or not,
whether they're trolling or not,
like come on like Dan is not the way.
The way is.
Let them talk and expose the goofiness of what they're saying.
If there's some validity to your argument and if there was no validity to your
argument,
consider what they're saying.
Like that's,
that's how human beings interact with each other.
You don't call them death threats because some chick likes vaginas.
She's on team vagina.
She's,
you know,
I mean,
that's her thing.
She loves women.
She thinks that women should be better represented in video games.
She's Hashtag feminists,
like I said,
what do you want?
Why is that really affecting you?
She's stopping you from voting and she stopped sensibilities.
Dammit.
Man.
It's funny.
It's fascinating.
It's cute.
They're trying to change video games.
You know,
Laura Croft seemed pretty feminine to me.
Sheree strong,
sure big titties.
The old gun flapping around.
I liked them better than they were just like six polygons.
It's just like aggressive triangles that could jab your eye.
This video game thing is very fascinating to me because on one hand,
uh,
I see it as like all these people resisting the radical left,
the radical left in there,
their ideas of what should and shouldn't be acceptable in our culture.
And on the other hand I see it as a bunch of fucking babies that are like
freaking out and getting crazy about some people's opinions.
It don't even matter.
I get the old ethics and video games thing.
There's definitely a point in that,
but it seems to have branched out way further than that.
It got corrupted immediately and now there's no like the originals what it is,
right.
Original argument I believe was not so much about that.
It was actually about ethics in video game journalism and they were trying to
prove that these blogs where you know,
getting paid or colluding with each other or bang in the same chair.
Exactly.
It all,
it all came down to that but,
and there's a valid gripe there.
There's a valid argument,
but the movement was so quickly co opted and we see,
you know we,
you and I yapped about occupy at length and then was eight.
That was in many cases a physical manifestation that was a physical movement
that is much harder to coopt,
but you can
expertly do that as we saw pretty easily when it's a digital movement,
when it can be usernames and there's astroturfing or there's members of a group
claiming that they're acting on behalf of the entire Hashtag your opted
overnight.
So what we're seeing,
we're seeing that go on in Ferguson,
we saw the undercover cops in Oakland that we're in the Eric Gardner protest.
They were,
they were pointing guns at people that were pointing cameras at them.
You're going to see those sort of agent provocateurs whenever you have some sort
of a large scale movement and if it's beneficial for them to insight some sort
of action that allow them to bring cops in like a loophole in the law,
like smash a few windows,
right?
Oh they smashed windows to move the cops in.
Boom.
Start arresting people.
Who is,
who is managing those windows?
I fucking saw everybody thrown rocks.
Arrest them.
All Zip ties.
Yup.
All around.
I mean that shit happens.
So if that shit happens with the police,
wouldn't you assume the two people that grow in at it,
whether it's the left or the right,
whether it's the gamers or the Gamer gators or the fucking feminists or the
men's rights advocates,
everybody's playing dirty there.
There's a lot of people that troll accounts.
There's people that are pretending to get death threats and they don't.
There's people that are sent in real death threats.
There are cons.
There's men that are pretending to get death threats from the feminists that are
fake.
There's all sorts of fuckery going on.
There's all sorts of anyone's involved.
Everyone,
I'm on a fucking mission.
I'm a part of a group.
Hi Am I came her gator right not your shield.
You fucks and it's like it becomes like a part of your life.
It becomes something you're excited to Hashtag.
Right and then agree with all these other people that are hashtagging that are
going after that fucking feminist bitch.
She's trying to ruin my games like she is she or is she just saying she doesn't
like them?
I mean,
what power does she have?
She's got a fucking youtube channel,
like she's not stopping any video games from being made.
She's not.
She's like,
keep you from buying them.
You how much fucking money is in world of Warcraft or any color.
You really think that they're going to let some chick who's got a youtube page
that's going to change anything about these games that you love?
No,
she's saying she thinks they're a part of the male patriarchy and they're
fucking horrible toxic masculinity examples like somewhat let her talk,
keep playing.
Why get offline?
Why not stay online and play and well,
why worry about what does she have any power?
She had congress woman and she's running for president,
right?
What the fuck man?
Oh,
you're mad that a bunch of people agree with her.
What are you crazy?
You want to get in arguments with people that you don't agree with and you don't
even know.
You want to get in the middle of them and just start duking it out back out
there.
There's
someone say a single remotely disparaging or critical thing about the only pass
time that I have are my favorite pass time.
You know.
Exactly.
Shouted down,
fucking shut it down.
We love that because I feel like look,
shutting off the Internet to,
to an entire country,
to a society if North Korea is blacked out because we flipped the switch,
we fired up the low orbiting ion cannon and blasted their internet out.
That can be dangerous in most cases.
That can be very dangerous and detrimental to an entire population.
But in the case of North Korea where I doubt that the average citizen has access
to any semblance of the real internet,
you know,
they're,
I mean,
they're eating salt from their minds right now.
It's not like they're,
they're popular.
So rude.
Realize,
um,
sure.
Uh,
yes,
I am.
Thank you.
Say that they'll take that,
they'll put it in quotes and you'll be in trouble.
They won't.
Well,
yes they are,
but they would do that anyways over there on their propaganda posters,
tweeters.
Here's the thing.
The defense representative North Korea takes me out of context.
There's worse battles that I have to fight today.
This is what I think we should do.
Do you,
do you think this is harming regular average joes?
In north.
Cool.
I think they're fucks Ville.
If I'm paying attention to the government propaganda,
which I am,
I think there Foxville.
If you listen to anybody that's survived those,
those horrible prison camps and if any of those stories even remotely true,
didn't have 10% of his true,
those people are fucked over there.
Right?
I think we should by North Korea.
We should go how much you guys want for this whole place.
Just go in there and buy it.
I bet it'd be surprisingly cheap.
It sucks.
How much could it cost?
Seriously?
How much can North Korea if we just went in and bought the whole country,
bought the whole government said,
listen,
there's we're gonna.
We're gonna just by you guys.
Like how much would the world have to chip in for the world buys North Korea and
has a like [inaudible] first global democratic society.
It'll be North Korea.
We just cleaned the whole place up like everybody,
you know,
you get some money scatter out across the four corners of the world.
The four kingdoms go wherever you want,
but we,
we own North Korea now.
We would lose such a good boogie man.
There's such a good boogie man to have cause they do have a new bogeyman that
Mike Myers Myers was on Saturday night live is Dr Evil Evil and like call it out
Kim Jong or whatever.
And it's recently.
Yeah,
this Saturday.
And he actually,
he pulled some good punches.
It was good.
It was a good roast.
A little baby roast.
You mean he hit him with some good punches?
They didn't pull them.
Poland pulled off some good offs and coupled off some good punches.
That's funny man.
I think that this is a weird time to have a guy in this day and age that is an
actual real dictator like Hitler styles is any like,
can y'all 30 or 29 pound around with Dennis Rodman?
I mean,
what is that to Dennis Rodman speak Korean or does he speak English?
He speaks to a universal language.
Universal language of the slam.
He can that man dunks and that's all,
it was just more of a rebounder.
But I see what you're saying.
You get what I'm saying?
It's a sportsman's analogy.
I love Athletic Games.
I love all sports teams and sporting events and score points and I think you're
being sarcastic.
We talking about,
I love that you like your video games and love my video games man.
Do you love them?
I know you.
Do you like athletic events?
I love him.
Do you?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Play like Madden,
Madden football.
No,
it's funny,
I don't the the virtual manifestation of a physical activity is always odd to
me.
You know Madden and looks pretty dope.
No,
no,
no.
It's great.
It's I,
it's a great game but for me it's like,
oh I love football.
I would go play.
I would go and throw a football around here.
That kind of gun get out and do it kind of sometimes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Just off your cowboy boots and get back on the horse.
Shut up.
Fucking little piece of Straw.
Like a wheat,
a little piece of wheat hanging out of the corner of your mouth.
Spittoon was those dudes walking around with wheat sticking out of the corner of
the mouth doing stupid.
That's nice.
In the earth.
That doesn't taste good.
Sales piece of wheat.
You're chewing on like an asshole.
So avatar man,
they're getting in touch with their earth there.
Is that what it is?
Mm hmm.
But it's genetically modified.
Monsanto,
you getting some weird pesticides into your system so bad.
It's like a little nicotine sticks.
You're chewing coming out of the ground.
Avatar,
depression,
frack and Rod,
I'd like to chew on it.
Get some residual chemical goo.
Have you heard of any movie ever where they associate a depression to withdrawal
from the reality that's in that movie other than Avatar?
Do you think though,
this whole depression thing was just marketing from the movie?
Cause I mean my girlfriend,
that's all she does all day is make bullshit articles to promote shit.
Like totally,
totally plausible,
totally plausible.
We created a Hashtag avatar depression.
I went,
got 20 fake accounts to retweet it.
That would be the case
except for the fact that I saw furry convention one time I was in Philadelphia
or Pittsburgh Rather,
um,
just completely randomly were there for the UFC and it happened to be a furry
convention in the saint and looking around at all those people that are wearing
all these costumes and running around hugging each other and dancing together.
I'm like fucking everything.
Anything's possible.
Well it's all pie.
Anything see say play.
They yeah,
we can put on a silver Fox suit and fuck each other.
Anything is possible.
My friend.
There's a lot of God damn people that are just different.
I'll never like it was a year three g four was covering comicon and all the,
like the director called up all the crumbs like got to get up here right away,
get up here and it came up and to Peel back the curtains and he's like look and
in the tower across the way,
full on fucking furry orgy with you know,
chicks with their Fox ears pressed against the glass and they were all fucking
in a row just on display.
And I was like,
Ma,
Lsu comicon plus human,
whatever.
Babies are going to pop out of there.
Yeah.
I love when doors get together like that.
I think it's awesome.
I was thinking that the other day because I was thinking like how much I love
like a good comic book movie,
Lincoln,
Good Avengers,
movie theaters.
The galaxy.
Uh,
yes.
Yeah.
Fucking great.
Yeah,
it's really good.
Very interesting.
I'd loved um,
um,
what we're talking about earlier,
the watchman.
I loved that.
Um,
big Avengers fan,
you know,
I think those movies are fun.
I just stood there fun to me.
They,
they,
they fill some sort of a childish need for like exciting things.
So when I see like a whole convention,
like a comic con convention where people like,
you know,
in their forties can like unabashedly talk about how much they loved the hulk.
Right?
Right.
And a judgment free zone.
How much they judgment comes from someone who thinks they'd like hulk more than
you and wants to catch you on a piece of information.
Something like the wrong,
more Ghostrider trivia than you do.
I got the tats man to prove it.
I got nick cage on my inner thigh.
There has to be a guy who has all ghost rider tattoos.
I would get it.
Pull that up.
Ghost
man with ghost rider tattoos.
Let's just have a,
a random wild Google search man with ghost rider tattoos.
I know there's a ghost rider tattoo because I bet there's some women that have a
nick cage tramp stamp.
Yeah.
I want to see the floating around.
Ben Affleck.
Dare Devil Tattoo.
Someone went all it was announced there will be somebody.
There's a lot of images in Scholes,
man.
There's the bike.
Look at the bike on the back.
Fuck got mad at her.
He's chasing the demon in the bottle dudes.
Well,
did you see the skull,
Abraham Lincoln one at the top.
I know it's a little unrelated,
but did you see that in the suggested Oh wow.
What the fuck?
Whoa.
It's like decomposing Lincoln.
People were creepy.
Alfred e Neuman.
Why worry about the theater?
Why would anybody do that to Lincoln asshole?
Yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of ghost rider tattoos.
Holy thinking would be sweet.
Dude,
I saw some,
someone posted a link to a on Twitter yesterday to three d tattoos like,
or they buy based off the perspective.
Yeah.
If you find the link,
there's like the top 11 three d tattoos and they had these,
just like what they're doing now with like shading and color is to try to trick
your mind into thinking things are three dimensional and you're like,
what?
I really want to see them in real life because what's the thing from the camera
angle,
it looks like the,
the,
their arm is collapsing,
but from the right side it looks like you got a giant droopy black,
nothing going down your arm,
you know,
that's awesome.
But that's,
we're looking at Spiderman like a spider man logo through regards torn chest.
That's amazing how good that looks.
Yeah.
But there's,
there's a gang of those,
dude,
I wonder if there's some practical makeup going on with that too.
Like he has to shade that in the morning.
That Butterfly Fuck.
Yeah.
Have you seen street art that's like this?
They all think of chocolate or,
yeah,
those guys.
That's again,
that's all perspective stuff.
So it's like from that one angle,
that butterfly looks awesome from the side.
It looks like you have a mole,
a giant butterfly shape,
mold and Nathan Click on that lady.
Oh my God.
That's nuts.
That is so crazy.
Yeah.
To dating a girl like that though and having to see that when you're trying to
fuck or how about coming on?
That's what,
yeah,
little come and write and that things I little advising for your chest.
Whoa.
She's got a lot.
Look at that.
She's got like fairy friends hunted dude up in the left up up to the left.
I don't think that's real.
Look at that.
Look at her.
I click on that.
What the fuck man?
She got some,
some cheap pellets coming.
Our pedals below her eyeball.
Fuck all that to make up the hope.
That's not even a real [inaudible].
Oh my God.
That's a pretty good
ah shit.
Holy Shit Man.
Baby on here.
That's pretty sweet.
I had a,
a,
a three dimensional map on his back with like,
um,
like a sextant over it.
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
A cat living on her side.
Cheshire cat peeking out of the side of the road.
Eyeballs are
amazing.
Look,
I got a lawyer for you.
[inaudible] lighter guy meets a Cheshire cat girl.
She's like,
I just can't respect your,
oh my God.
That's great.
Whoa.
That's dope.
Like I got a sweet 3d natty ice can on my abs.
It's like,
why?
That's the object you went to make three d.
There's some serious fucking tattoo artists.
These neck eyeball.
Nobody's saying you can't see it unless he does that.
That's cool.
Well,
you would know something's there.
You're like,
what's going on down there?
This guy has a high ball.
Oh my God.
You know she didn't do that.
No,
she didn't do that.
That's got to be picked out or something.
Or is it real?
What does it say?
Oh my God,
just file.
Name is phase three d Ted [inaudible],
Ted's face,
tattoo dot.
JPG.
Oh my
God.
That might be real shit if it is
hit random.
Let's see what else pops up on this climb stairs.
I guarantee you that someone's done that this.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Just because it looks like a normal girl.
That's what's freaking you out.
I bet that with some subdermal implants going on,
you could really fuck some shit up.
You could really make sure you never get a job at a bank.
Yes.
Check dermal implants
put on his feet forever.
That's strange,
Bro.
How weird.
Oh,
look at this.
No tattoos for Kevin prayer.
How about super creative on your back?
Hello.
It'll be there in like gladiator logo.
Super Creative,
right?
With that,
I want to get someone to make it in like sacred geometry.
That's what I want.
Now I want you to do it and you fucking calls Satan.
If you didn't know if I get that men use a Wedgie board at the same time,
then the than the demon corridors open.
Yeah.
He fucks up like one room.
Just changes.
It should've pointed left points,
right?
Right.
Satan's like you called bitch.
Dude.
What I'm hearing is he suing me for copyright infringement for trademark
infringement turns you into the ghost rider.
Oh yeah.
You gotta live your life for the rest of your life flying around.
Apparently Nicolas Cage did a new movie,
a new,
a super religious movie.
A version of the left behind series,
you know,
really behind movies.
Ever say familiar.
I haven't seen the movies.
Kirk Cameron did them.
Right?
Like I had VHS copies of them because they're wonderful.
They're fucking hilarious.
It's about the rapture.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the books are a hugely popular Christian books.
I mean,
they're there.
They've sold millions of copies and the,
that's the plot point.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's just,
you know,
Jesus comes,
it takes everybody to have,
and everybody's going,
Woo,
Woo.
Let's say some of the week I'll get,
oh,
guess we're all sinners.
Everybody else went to heaven.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's there in heaven.
Oink,
oink.
Aliens came down and ate him.
You fucking idiots.
The eight,
all the lemmings.
They were willing to get on the spaceship.
Jesus.
Jesus at this patient.
Yeah,
I know what I felt could do.
Are you going to heaven?
You fucking queers while you gay marriage could look good luck.
You're gonna burn in hell.
I'm going to be feasting at the garden right next to St Pete and we're going to
be flowing robes
and now convert.
All my animals are going to be there.
All animals,
all dogs go to heaven.
All your parents,
friends,
all your friends that died and drunk accidents.
They didn't know any better.
Sure.
God took the man.
They're all going to be in heaven waiting for you.
It's going to be amazing.
Every day is going to be super bowl Sunday every day.
I love that.
Like once you're up there though,
like all bets are off because you made it to heaven and there is no,
you don't really get booted out of heaven.
Right.
Forgiveness is sort of the,
that's like the,
that's the motto there.
That's the emo.
I bet you just repress the gayness enough so that when you get raptured then you
just suck in all the dicks on clouds.
No,
that's not how it works.
That's exactly how it works.
I can't go to heaven if you've got all that gay in your heart.
If that's forgiven,
you're getting your funnel.
You have to get rid of the gay.
I'll have to pray it away before you get on the spaceship.
Exactly.
Ah,
you got to pray the gay away.
Got It.
You got to pray it away or you know he can't have it in your head.
That's the whole idea.
When they do get to heaven,
they just hang out,
right?
Yeah.
What do you,
what the fuck do you do up there?
No one,
no one ever adequately explained adequate Lee.
What?
No one ever explained to me.
What happened after Jesus came back from the dead.
Did he die of old age?
Well,
how come he's not still around?
Like he came back to life,
right?
He was dead for three days,
came back to life,
freaked everybody out.
They all wrote about it and then what?
Where's he now?
Where was he then he didn't do anything like there's no great stories like,
and then he stopped all the wars and then he fed all the poor people and he
decided to do,
was going to educate people on what his dad and that everyone's going to believe
him.
Cause he came back from the dead and he's going to live for a hundred years and
change.
It's like,
nope,
nope.
That's equal to the bottom of the bag,
bitches back and I'm gone again.
He just came back from the dead.
Tada releases doves and then poof,
disappears.
In a way.
It's a lot like the Adam and Eve story with like a cursory examination of the
facts in the story.
If you were on the first 48 and if you are one of those officers sat down across
from the person,
he'd be like,
okay,
let me get this straight so you show me.
Is it all the people came from a guy named Adam and his wife named eve,
so they had sex and they made kids and then I guess they just start fucking
their kids or their kids started fucking each other.
Everybody just fucked each other that they had to is the only way you can make
people's people have to have sex with each other?
Is that what you're trying to tell?
Me and the guy on the other side be like,
I need to talk to my lawyer.
I hope that season two of cereal tired out examination shows,
that would be exactly what would happen.
They would come,
they would come in and I'll go,
okay,
well let's just,
let's just draw this.
We're going to draw this out.
Let's start with Robert here and figures.
We're going to have them.
This is a male figure,
like one of those bathrooms where you have like the bathroom icon with a girl
with the skirt.
Sure.
And then the guy would skirt,
this is dad.
This is mom.
So Dad,
mom,
fuck.
And they have kids.
And who starts fucking first,
right?
Cause the sun.
Fuck.
The mom wasn't a mate of his bone.
Wasn't that part of her?
Adam was made from the bone.
Some of them was made from a range,
right?
A piece of a rib bone eve was made from the rib of,
has made from the rib.
Okay.
And of course,
always blame it on chicks.
Eve gave into that snake shit.
That's a fucked us up.
She really about you.
Imagine the
idea that one chick back when you couldn't even read,
no one had a cell phone.
There was no internet and no cars,
no planes,
no fucking television.
Right?
This one chick fucked it up for everybody.
Like we have all eternity.
What are convenient way to like to,
to blame one person,
right?
And one gender for everything that we've ever done.
I want to believe that the lapel footage of her grabbing that apple and taking a
bite would be on Worldstar
oh
fuck
woes dog.
When the world stopped you and Adam founder eating an apple and started beating
around,
that would be on Worldstar.
This is forever when we just allow it gets forever.
Are you allowed to beat your wife in the Bible?
Is that legal?
Yeah,
it's legal in the Quran,
right?
Depends on what she does.
Right.
Domestic violence,
which,
which uh,
is the Bible allow it?
I know like there's certain depends on budget,
which revision.
I think you're going with,
there's certain Muslim texts.
David have alluded to the idea that a man should be able to beat his wife.
Right?
Right.
Is that true?
Is that,
am I making this up?
Let's say?
No,
I think so.
It's all of your interpretation.
Okay.
Let's look up why you're allowed to beat slaves and certain parts of the Bible.
Like that's for sure.
You're allowed to own and reprimand your slaves.
Are you allowed to reprimand them?
Yeah.
You're allowed to come.
And Mary Madeline or whatever her name was.
No,
you're not allowed to commoner.
She's just like got pregnant.
I magically,
that was a,
that was how it went down.
Cover up.
Yeah.
Does Islam allow wife reading?
Okay.
This isn't an actual Islam,
um,
website.
Snopes comic website.
Know some husbands are violent.
They said the Quran allows them to beat their wives there.
Any logical explanation giving given regarding men being allowed to beat their
wives as stated in,
I don't want to butcher this.
Serrat on Nisa and I s s oh,
you nailed it.
Verse 34 and the Name of Allah,
Most Gracious,
Most Merciful,
all praise and thanks are due to our law and peace and blessings be upon his
messenger.
Okay.
Ba,
ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba.
I'm trying to find out about wife beaten.
I Dunno.
It doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
Same thing with the honor killings.
Some people will quote certain passages and say,
well,
you're allowed fit is as long as your honor was offended,
you were allowed to kill somebody.
But someone else will quote another passage and say,
no,
I'll,
murder is wrong.
It says it right there.
And some chapter.
Yeah.
This doesn't make any sense,
but there's different religion.
The president of the US Lamek
Society of North America states according to the Quran,
the relationship between the husband and the wife should be based on mutual love
and kindness.
I'll ask says,
and among his signs is this,
that he created for you mates from among yourselves that Ye may dwell and
tranquility with them,
and he has put love and mercy between your hearts verily in that are signs for
those who reflect.
See,
that's the problem,
man.
Whenever you're reading old shit,
they write it like that.
Okay.
What the fuck did I just say?
Whenever you're reading a tweet,
it could be that confusing.
This is,
no,
this is the thing that they're trying.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Right.
This is the statement that they're trying to,
um,
to conceive as being said that it allows wife beating,
right.
Notice they still use that language.
Yes.
An IRS.
But also when like talent contracts in court,
it's like,
yeah.
Anything legal.
Anytime someone's trying to fuck you or trying to preclude you from fucking them
somehow.
It's always very early in perpetuity.
And the various similar to that of the ancillary spinoff of the CPM of the,
what the fuck are you trying to say to me?
Yeah,
yeah,
that,
that I just read.
Yeah.
That is what they're using to diverse,
saying that on its surface,
meaning taking it to allow wife beating that,
that statement that I just said.
Sure.
What the fuck,
how it,
what does that even mean?
And among his signs is this,
that he created for you mates from among yourselves that Ye may dwell and
tranquility with them and he has put love and mercy between your hearts verily
in that are signs for those who will reflect.
How was that wife beating?
Well,
what the fuck does that even mean?
It's just like when you read old shit like this,
like really ancient scripts.
It's very difficult to figure out what the hell there they were saying.
Sure.
And this is just a translation.
I mean,
did you understand it in the language that's being spoken?
It's a completely different statement.
I'm sure they literally don't have in some languages,
they don't have words for the thing that you're saying or describing.
There is literally no word for it.
So right there you're translation or your interpretation is broken.
Well,
my friend Steve lived in Hong Kong for a while and he spoke Chinese.
He learned Chinese and one of the things that he said was that one of the things
that people misconstrue about Chinese people and they speak English is that
they're rude,
but their language is much more direct.
They don't speak in the past,
they're just doing,
you know,
you have dog,
like do you have a dog?
Have you had a dog?
They don't have those.
You have dog.
They'll like say it.
Right,
and that's how they can,
which is a state or a question.
You'll figure that out from the context.
Yeah,
it's some,
it's really interesting to hear him explain while they're,
while there's so many misconceptions about the way a Chinese people communicate
with English because their language is so different,
it's confusing as fuck.
Like to grasp the subtleties of our language.
They don't exist culturally in their language.
So I'm like,
I was trying to get them to explain to me like,
how would you say I used to play the fiddle?
How would you say that?
You know,
I don't think you say it.
You say,
I play fiddle,
I play fiddle.
Not,
you know,
I'd really fiddle.
Not now.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know how the fuck you would say it,
but you can't say the way we think you would say it.
So when they translate,
uh,
Chinese to English,
it's like,
you know,
you'll go now,
you'll get out of here.
Right.
It's weird.
It's a weird sort of cultural disconnect.
Sure.
That's what this shit too,
man.
That's why in 17 years from now,
we're all speaking Emoji.
That's all it's going to be.
Do you have to call?
It's going to be,
I'm going to be that.
We're not talking right.
We're just gonna be beaming.
Thoughts.
Yeah.
We're going to be doing is getting,
someone's going to be on the Google protocol and you're going to have the
windows one or whatever and your android is going to mix the message that comes
over to my iMessage.
She going to be just like a Cordy keyboard.
She universal.
Even if it's not the best.
I'm going to figure out one and it's going to be universal.
Someone's going to run [inaudible],
someone's gonna run some other shit,
some Linux distro and be like,
I don't think I think differently,
man.
Have you ever really think differently?
Keyboard if you're using one of them now?
I try.
I tried for like a week,
but I was so that was raised on in the Qwerty in the [inaudible] that I could
not adjust to it.
People who have no idea what the fuck we're talking about.
The reason why your keyboard is set up the way it is,
where it's his Courtney on the top is not because it's the most efficient way.
It's because back when they had like a real type writer,
we pressed a button and a gear moved a thing,
a mechanical stamp and left its mark on paper.
Yeah,
and they had a lego ink ribbon.
Yup.
Punch the ribbon down back when that was going on.
You couldn't do it too fast because if he did,
they would get all mashed up together.
When my grandfather had a typewriter and it would always get mashed up and you'd
have to go in there and unpeel the little fuckers a little arms.
So we tried to play a cord on it.
Nope.
It was all lenses.
Super Mechanical.
And so they devised this,
this positioning to actually make it more difficult to do it fast.
Like this is not the most efficient way.
This is the most efficient way to keep the common case.
I thought it was also commonly used letters away from each other so they don't
got to get your teaching because they don't smash into each other because of the
commonly used letters were right next to each other.
It would be easier to do.
I'll be doing next fingers all day and they'd be smashing against each other and
getting stuck all the time.
See,
I always,
that's fascinating.
I always thought it was,
it was arranged that way due to technical limitations and have to place letters
in certain areas.
But B,
I thought they were grouped by usage in terms of words and phrases so that your
hands could easily reach the things.
I'm pretty sure that's what I assumed.
So if you,
if you,
if you've read an ounce on it,
then you'd have more knowledge on it than I,
but pretty sure I'm right about this.
And the divorce,
that keyboard,
is that what you're saying?
Does that,
doesn't that happen?
Isn't that the layout and think it is?
Yes.
In divorce,
the guy from tech TV trying to work.
Okay,
well he created a great keyboard,
sorry,
g four bottom and ruined them.
I get it.
Read it.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It's like me running when I hosted the man show.
You'll never live it down right now.
Oh,
it's all good.
I'm going to bring up,
I'm going to bring it back though and I'm going to do it right.
The going boy you go going to,
but I've never met anybody that's used at other keyboard.
No,
there was a time there was,
I remember like when I was 12 or 13 year olds,
years old,
there was a keyboard that came out that could be positioned on your thighs or on
your uh,
the hand,
like the,
the,
the handles of your chair or whatever and you placed your fingers physically
into these like little holes and up would be f down would be d left would be
this,
right,
would be bad or whatever.
And then you had shift commands,
whatever.
And basically they could put exponentially more keys mathematically speaking
within just a finger movement.
Nobody wanted to be trained on this new system,
but the handful of guys that develop this or whatever,
there's videos of them putting their hands into this thing and just just doing
little fucking street fighter combos and it's just spitting words onto the thing
because there's no travel time.
You can just tick,
tick,
tick.
Those do it that way.
Fucking awesome.
Would have to be so weird to go back and forth from that to a regular children
for keyboard.
No,
I wouldn't have,
I mean sure,
but imagine putting that into gloves then and just you could do that anywhere.
I love this guy on a recently Zoltan Istvan who's a futurist in fortune teller
and a box at the [inaudible] actually smart guy.
He's a big,
he's a,
one of the guys from the um,
the uh,
what the word they use singularity university,
singularity university.
Um,
you know,
they're all trying to try to get a handle on transhumanism and what all know,
but he was saying that he believes within 20 years the written language and
spoken language will all go away and it'll all be done back and forth through
like headsets.
These headsets,
his ability that found to transmit a thought and actual thought.
Sure.
Telepathically through the Internet,
that that's going to be like standard technology in 20 years.
We're all going to just use that,
right?
Imagine we'd be like Cecil here and we're talking inside of each other,
but when we sit here,
why would we even sit here?
We'll just connect remotely.
We'll have a mine site.
It's fun to like Skype while you're looking at somebody.
Yeah,
but I'll be able to show you what I look like.
I'll be able to project that image into your head and someone else will be able
to connect to our shared image.
It's true and they won't be able to contribute,
contribute to it.
There'll be moderation.
What about,
you know,
I'm in touch with Evan Perez.
We'll synthesize that as well.
The touch is great,
but you could,
if you can have the fucking demolition man sex,
that's going to be even more real.
I'm gonna be able to mind.
Fuck you.
That's coming,
right?
Oh absolutely.
Virtual Reality Vr is happening and look,
you can train with just with electromagnetic would just put the helmets that you
strap on that you know,
read the electrical stimulation.
You could sit down today with off the shelf technology and train a computer.
When I think the letter f this is what fires off my brain and I think f,
F,
f over and over again.
I'm not visualized pictures of F and you could roughly train a computer to
understand when these synapses fire off.
This is what I'm thinking about that exists today.
That exists right now that technology is going to get miniaturized.
It's going to get flushed out.
They're gonna,
they're gonna have 100,000 people contribute their brain scans to some Google
project.
So right out of the box,
it's going to have an averaging of what most human brains think of when they
think horse or f or the combination of those two,
which sounds sexual and out of the box.
And it's going to well,
to a lot of people,
Joe,
again,
let's not judge and fuck,
I said F I didn't say fuck.
So out of the box,
10% of whatever is going to work.
It's going to have Siri like accuracy with this little fucking beanie that
you're going to put on and that's going to happen in what,
seven years?
10 years?
Yeah.
If we don't blow ourselves up or don't get hit by a meteor or a supervolcano or
right quick for sure.
We're going to have some mind bending stuff in just a few years.
It's really weird to just think about the possibilities.
It's going to change what we feel is important and not important.
It's going to really,
I think it's going to redefine how we even how even think about other people,
right?
We're going to be so much closer to each other.
It's going to be very strange.
It's also interesting to think about like the,
the process of thought to transmitting into any sort of medium to conversation,
to typing,
to whatever.
There's a barrier there,
right?
There's a,
there's a time that lapses where you,
some people don't,
but most formulate a thought.
They worked through it.
How do I want to say this?
How do I want to express this?
What's that going to be when that shit is just firing raw in your brain?
Well,
we have to like form the thought and then go,
okay,
send like a tweet where we have that over there.
Just because to me,
raw fucking data coming out.
Like how is that conversation going?
Right?
How was that conversation?
We're going to,
we've got to handshake like old modems and be like,
Yo,
I want to tap into your brain.
You get your permission.
Okay.
Now we have this mental chat room.
People gonna be mad if you say no.
Right?
Why don't you let me tap into your brain,
Bro,
right there.
Knocking on your mind.
Yeah.
I'm a fan.
I loved you on remote control,
Dude.
Fucking,
I'm a Nerdist fan,
bro.
No,
no,
that's not me.
That's not even a movie.
That's a different guy.
Yeah,
no,
bro,
Bro.
Bro,
you're the fucking tosh guy.
I love your liver.
It's going to happen when you give it a timekeeper or were you wanting a high
five high five,
bro.
Damn.
It went through three hours.
That's three.
Three.
I'll tell you about g four IOWASCA or any lounge right next to other one.
Next time you live in la,
man.
[inaudible] man.
No,
I really do.
I was,
and I'll tell you as much as it was [inaudible] and I miss you,
I miss you too by the way.
Oh,
sweet.
Uh,
as much as it might sound like,
like the billowing of smoke through an asshole,
like it was really amazing and beautiful to see how you're doing what you do
directly affected the lives for the better of so many people in such a ballsy,
a drastic way.
It's not to carry waking.
You met 20 freaks in the fucking jungle resort.
Okay.
I deal with the extremes.
All right.
I deal with extremists,
crazy people.
People willing to go to the jungle and drinks a fucking vile tea.
I think.
I think you,
uh,
enabled people to explore extremes and push themselves into places that would
normally be off limits and uncomfortable and to be quite honest,
saved people's lives.
I saw people who literally said this was a last resort.
If I don't feel any better after this,
I'm done.
I'm punching out.
Well,
that's beautiful people,
John there because of your podcast,
so thank you.
On behalf of them.
I told them I would relay that and it was important to me to do that.
So Nice of you to do that.
But it's easy as fucking,
I don't deserve shit.
And all of you would do the same thing if you were kind of situation that I'm
in.
All of you would express yourself in a way.
If you had the freedoms that I have,
99% of all people who lived my life would do exactly what I'm doing.
It's not that hard,
man.
Just have conversations about shit that's already out there.
That is,
especially when it comes to psych and dogs,
they things that could really change people's lives and everyone's treating them
as if they're frivolous.
Nonsense.
Everyone's treating me like,
yeah man,
we took some ass.
We got fucked.
Call it drugs anymore.
I purposely have changed that.
It's,
it's,
it's a plant medicine.
Oh that's you used beat.
You're going to lose a lot of the right wing people.
Oh yeah.
There's a lot of the Republicans been,
they're not gonna be using my Squarespace discount code anymore.
All those fucking tea party members listening to me.
Plant medicine,
sot nom,
um,
psychedelic drugs.
It's okay to say drugs.
Don't be scared of drugs.
That's why you go to the drugstore folks.
That's why there's so many trucks,
doors.
You go there to get on medicine.
The word drug is a,
a confused word.
Correct.
Fucked up.
Just,
I'm trying to avoid it because I think it starts a conversation on unequal
footing to guess what's in this Mug.
What is it that caveman coffee?
No,
caveman coffee is,
please tell me everything from rugs.
It's drugs.
It's caffeine.
I had to take us with chocolate.
Caffeine.
When I was in Peru.
The biggest headache I got was because I couldn't drink coffee for three fucking
days.
Wow.
It wasn't the IOWASCA,
it wasn't the Chuma.
It was the fucking Folgers that didn't,
didn't like knock it out of you and the IOWASCA didn't knock it out of you.
You still wanted coffee?
Oh No.
I mean after the first one it was,
I mean,
migraine leading up to it because I'd been off of it for two or three days and
then after the Iowasca happened,
who gives a fuck about caffeine?
That's child's play.
Wiffle bat to my soul.
Right,
but aren't you supposed to not take coffee like days leading up to the RMS
customize and you drank any?
We're not supposed to do,
it's some say 48 some say 72 hours before.
So I was off of it for over 72 hours.
So that's why it was the three days.
Correct you?
Yeah.
And no sugar,
no salt,
no any of that.
I mean,
you've had that conversation with others,
but next time,
next time.
Yeah,
next time for sure.
Yeah.
Kevin Pereira.
Thanks.
Joe Rogan is my friend.
Thank you man.
It's always good to have young Grad something.
All of this success.
Brian was going to see grand stole yours too.
I mean,
I want to go outlet shopping anytime at which is me.
He'll talk to you about celebrities only.
So we talked to Jamie gave us some great advice on helping our podcast studio
long as well.
So thank you.
Bye.
[inaudible] this show is over,
buddy,
for tuning in January 2nd.
I am at the Mirage in Las Vegas with Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and Duncan Trussell.
Then January 30th,
we returned to the Mirage with Tony Hinchcliffe and Ian Edwards.
Good Lord,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
why be that's because a,
there's you fcs twice a month in Vegas.
Um,
and New Year's Eve,
I am at the Improv in Hollywood with a young Tony Hinchcliffe and the hilarious
eaten Ian Edwards to fucking awesome standup comics.
And Brian got anything going on or we have any time left?
Sure.
Alright,
well is there any time
he wants to play it?
Super creative dominated going on.
Super Create guy.tv Irvine Improv this week.
Uh,
and I'm also doing the Columbus,
Ohio with your vine and provide Tuesday does go say days everyday with
toys here.
I'm going to miss them.
Vegas January 23rd and Columbus,
Ohio with Joey Diaz the following week,
uh,
which is July,
having 20th squad.
Dot TV for details.
Super creative dot thing.
You want to plug some creative.com super creative.tv dot.
Do you get the point of this podcast?
They're the real housewives of horror.
Two guys,
one up,
tons of shows.
Doubt Joe Rogan.
Jihad.
So good.
See you soon.
Bye Bye folks.
Big Kid.
[inaudible].